[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this believe it
or not is Keenan Thompson I am so
thrilled not only that Keenan came on
the show I've been such a huge fan of
his for years and years we talk about
this in the episode but I I think he can
make anything funny even funnier he's
just an added value performer hilarious
and you're about to hear down to earth
balanced grounded and wonderful kind
interesting and fun human being so I am
thrilled that you are here I'm so glad
you're here and you're here I just said
that too many times a couple things to
plug up top I am on tour next up is
Denver I believe followed by St Louis uh
I think we're going to be adding
Bloomington Indiana all of these things
are going to be on
petehomes.com it's going to be a
wonderful little tour and if you already
came to a show thank you so much and if
you're going to be in the Los Angeles
area I do a live show once a month here
in La go to
largo-la.com look for Pete Holmes living
at Largo the next one is August 5th they
are always the highlight of my month
always star-studded with music and
Comedians and myself doing a nice long
set so that's always amazing go to
largo-la.com and if you like the show
why not try a pizza pick for those of
you who haven't heard the show before we
do ads a little differently we only do
spots for things that I actually use and
actually love like for example this that
I'm holding up for the camera right now
this is my Apollo Nero Nero any URL
neuro yeah neuro like neurology my
Apollo neuro it's the one piece of tech
a product really that has changed my
life the most in the past year hands
down Apollo neuro is a wearable that
helps your body recover from stress that
sends vibrations into your body mine's
on right now it's unclear and focus
right now I can barely hear it feel it
it's almost sub-perceptual but it gives
your nervous system the sensation of
being touched or held it's like a
virtual hug that calms your nervous
system down and helps you relax sleep
Focus or in my case right now be more
productive it's like a wearable hug for
your nervous system using touch therapy
to help you feel safe and in control you
can wear it on the wrist you can wear it
on your ankle you can even clip it on
the inside of your shirt helps you with
energy perhaps you feel more social and
open clear and focused rebuild and
recover which is great after workouts or
after stressful interactions calm which
is awesome for meditation unwind now and
I call that the try and stay asleep
setting and fall asleep how great is it
at night I put it on well I never took
it off it's on I go on my phone I hit
fall asleep and it gently lulls you to
sleep by introducing a rhythm and
slowing it down and gently slowly your
body gets the idea I'm safe and it's
okay to fall asleep chemical free helps
with all of these things helps with
symptoms of ADHD these oppose effects on
stress sleep with cognitive performance
and Recovery have been proven in
multiple clinical trials and real world
studies it's not woo-woo it's clinical
it's developed by a neuroscientist and a
board-certified psychiatrist who have
been studying the impacts of chronic
stress in humans for another 15 years
you can get 10 off support the show
support your body support your mind go
to apollonuro.com weird that's e-a-p-o
a-p-o-l-l-o-n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird
ten percent off seriously give it a try
also brought To Us by our friends at
onit and Alpha Brain this morning like
every morning I took some Alpha Brain
and before this episode you're about to
hear I took some Alpha Brain what is it
it's a new atropic which means it's
Earth grown ingredients that help your
brain with memory focus and
concentration it's incred edible for
recall it's incredible for Creative work
it's incredible for conversation it's
incredible for banging out emails it is
a huge secret weapon in my repertoire
when I need to get work done or do
anything that involves my brain taking
Alpha Brain two or three Alpha Brain 15
20 minutes before I do it is a game
changer I wish I knew about it in
college I'm so glad I know about it now
it's been years over six years that I
haven't done stand up a podcast written
script or even just gone on a date
without or just wanted to read a book
and maintain and hold on to more of it
without taking Alpha Brain before I
swear by it I give it to fans sometimes
because I know I keep it in my pockets
it's so fun it's so helpful Game Change
go to on it onnit.com weird you will get
10 off everything you see on that
landing page that's on it.com slash
weird alright everybody enjoy my chat
with my new friend Keenan Thompson I
can't believe it get into it we came in
in the carbon monoxide I know
let me give you the Standard carbon
monoxide update
on what you're walking into that's you
right there assistant
it is
it's a house I'm firing a guy going to
kind of put it out by himself it's just
like a what if you come adversity kind
of thing really yeah and it's new yeah
yesterday
yesterday we got a dude let me see the
dude dude with two buckets like oh he's
got a hoodie on it it looks overwhelming
but you got to do your thing anyway
go put the fire out yeah go put the fire
man isn't that life that is that is life
we got yeah I'm gonna include you yeah
I'm assuming there are differences in
our life uh I was just gonna tell you
you're you're more famous than I am and
you've been in a million things that I
love but I bet we're pretty similar we
are and yet
like 1am last night I woke up and just
kind of started thinking about
all the stuff isn't that when it like
Creeps in When You're vulnerable who is
this who is this [__] that lives in you
that goes like his guard is down and go
like Now's the Time Now's the Time
remember when he's relaxed when he's
relaxed this is the time to stress them
out it's the Paradox of life life is
I mean I guess you need it for the sake
of words like irony yeah it helps with
those you know but past that is it's
it's hard not to let that stuff creep in
when yeah like you said when your guard
is down and it feels like it's on fire
for me
if you want to freak me out like my
brain starts whispering to me it's
usually work or finances even though if
like because you're an adult now
you're an adult now yes welcome to your
adult life I have a daughter yeah I
don't have a wife but I I have a wife
you know what I mean I have my daughter
in a totally different way than I have
my wife but even if you have a wife
they're an adult as well you know what I
mean well she's my partner that's what I
mean exactly the daughter the child is
like a defensive full dependent yeah
that's a full FD and that and it's
looking to you you know for all of the
answers
for me it's about how old is she she's a
four and a half she's about to be yeah I
dropped her at camp this morning my
littlest is turning five on the 31st no
way yeah very similar age yeah and then
my big girl's nine she just turned nine
last month my the best little person
it's the best little person the best
because they say not to bum you out
everyone that listens to this pod knows
I'm about to say this around seven is
when their innocence sort of goes now
they start to become people yeah they
become people but it goes back to the
house on fire yep they get a little
sense right now my job it seems is just
kind of creating a bubble not a not a
bad bubble yeah sometimes people say
bubble in a bad way I mean like a safe
happy place look at kids TV everything
is high it's and it drives us crazy
absolutely because we're like this isn't
real but they don't know isn't that
terrible
well we know the House theme song for
like the Mickey Mouse Clubhouse
it can drive you crazy and it's like are
we talking about hot dog hot dog we are
hot diggity dog
come on
come on in the background and it's just
a marathon of it and the kid loves it
and it's doing you a favor but man yes
it runs up your spine as an adult
because yeah you're like this isn't how
the world is yes but stay innocent
and until they say around seven for you
for me for everybody not just your baby
because when I talk about my daughter
getting disillusioned or leaving the
Garden or whatever you want to say they
say it usually happens around seven
there's some disappointment something
shatters there's a tear in your nylons I
don't mean literally but like that
happens and it's never the same it's the
communal of the kids they start being
around more kids especially if they go
to school you know what I mean they just
start sharing more information at such a
hyper Pace yeah and sharing behaviors
you know that you don't show those kind
of behaviors to your child you know what
I'm thinking you're always on your best
behavior dude if you saw it I apologize
to my daughter you wouldn't believe it
first of all I've never heard my dad say
I'm sorry it's never happened so you're
trying to be different I'm driving
you're trying to move this yeah he moved
it forward to give him a little credit
he moved it Forward yes I'm moving in
another boy and I'm like a pawn I go to
yeah I'm gonna give myself exactly this
is the future but I just
was it this morning you can't say but
like this morning
oh it was last night I was putting her
to sleep I was rocking her I knew she
was over tired so I knew we were right
on the cusp of like this could be like a
a tantrum like a like something like she
doesn't even like yeah so I'm really
trying to get her to be tired and I'm
rocking her telling her a boring story
you know in the stories and they found
a cave
and it was warm that was a warm cave in
the dark
the warm cave you could hear droplets of
water I do that echoing in the
background
[Music]
laughs
I do that I go yeah I could hear the
wind set the set the stage dude it's
some it's fun for you it's because
you're you're a performer so that's fun
for you it is and I'm this isn't why I
do it I do it because it's fun for me
and I want her to be entertained
sometimes I tell her story so good that
her eyes go wide yeah and she won't and
then I have to be like yeah
pull it back
back down and mellow it was a desert
very dry there was nothing much to do or
say because the day was done and
everybody was going nine nine night
night Cactus oh my God you see my genius
the best good night Moon the best people
tease good night Moon I don't bow down
recognize recognize any chain that's
right if it was a good enough once and
it's done in 15 20 times it's a solid
idea that's right and people are ripping
it off with like have a good one chair
like that's because Goodnight Moon set
the set the standard that's right have a
good one chair that [__] works it
settles the kid now especially like kids
in cities yeah you know what I mean it
helps them process like what they've
been seeing all day especially in New
York like oh you think a kid around New
York around October they might see some
wild [__] we just chill I mean thank you
we took her to some Halloween parade
yeah I forget where we were it wasn't
New York it wasn't L.A yeah but some
dude might as well have had like dicks
on his face just come down and was like
and I'm like
you just gave us months and that's it
dude playing with the energy we're
talking about like the the
disillusionment is coming yeah they will
learn yeah I'm gonna help yeah [__] you
dude it's like when kids go yeah [__]
Santa Con yes [__] you're ruining it
you're killing it you can't have 30 000
sandals you're acting like there's no
kids in the city there's kids everywhere
a Santa pub crawl is an act of violence
and we have to explain this do what dude
I took my daughter to see Santa two
nights later we take her to a thing I
didn't know there was going to be a
Santa there there was a free range Santa
and my daughter's like that's not the
same Santa and I'm like it's not oh uh
here we go
um well Santa has a a lot of helpers
that help him out yeah and that's right
and this scary one looked like him he's
scary yes but Santa approves so I
wouldn't wear let's go get some food
yeah or just try to put her to sleep
there's a cave
and Santa knows where the cave is so you
don't have to worry about that sometimes
they're just counting the stories I'll
go and there's I took 10 steps oh my God
I remember nine like downloading like
the original Winnie the Pooh
no the book and it is dry
it is Christopher Robin not known for
his anecdote takes a while yeah it takes
a while to get to the bear
it's crazy you're not getting the Poo
page two you're learning about
Christopher in his world for a while and
then Pooh pops in and it yeah it's slow
and we already know the Dynamics like
it's a magical talking bear we gotta get
to it we get it but back then they had
to be like and you're not gonna believe
this you're not gonna but the bear could
talk can you believe it he opened his
mouth and he said Christopher
Christopher was aghast and took two
steps back then a third then a third
those eyes are getting heavy those eyes
are getting him a third and then a
fourth step back I think stories were
just written to put children to sleep
until recently either that or entertain
the writer in in subtleties because like
I guess like all the Disney stories are
like kind of really dark yeah yeah some
secret yeah I think they are once you
kind of
I don't want to say wake up because that
makes it sound like people are asleep I
just mean once you get wise to certain
themes yes I was watching Cop Land you
seen Copland absolutely you blew it
I gave you 10. you blew it you blew it
that that scene breaks my heart
ginormous cast That cast is everyone
crazy that cast is like the Last Supper
painting of American Italian actors yes
Keitel it explained De Niro the rap
report of it all and Rappaport culture
could not be more New York he he's a
Borough
in the exactly the freaking dictionary
rappaport's picture and that's why he
moves and runs and what's great is you
can sketch him in a dictionary like just
black and white and that that's about
what he looks like totally
yeah he represents a real like
cultural people like all in one person
and what I love about New York because
we were just there New York doesn't know
that they only exist there that kind of
guy oh my God saying [__] in a deli line
oh it's an East it's a Northeastern
Corridor thing yeah but it definitely
doesn't transfer oh no West you take
that dude I mean this is what my cousin
Vinnie is there's a million movies oh
yeah that are just what if one of these
guys are in Brooklyn yeah yeah it's the
migration and Boston too yeah I'm from
Boston yeah I it's it's insane you take
in fact I have taken my parents and
brought them to other states yeah and
everyone's like you're crazy things what
is this but if you puff your chest out
and like stand toe-to-toe with people
they love you for it you know what I
mean the world I'm hoping he likes my
little pale riff I'm afraid of him I'm
sure I'm sure he will he's just like oh
you saw that kid oh that's cool oh you
saw that oh you saw that no I'm not Bill
thank you he's Bill Burr he's New York
Burr Burr's the greatest he's the
greatest Boston voice I think I've ever
heard he's wonderful you know like what
a champion
in the skin of the people he's talking
to you know what I mean agree just
firing off about the ridiculous oh he
went in on Philadelphia I know I
remember that right I remember that was
sort of what broke him like a lot of us
knew bill yeah I knew I knew bill when
he was Billy Burr hilarious Billy Burr
yeah and he used to do the black circuit
yeah and everyone was like there's this
guy named Bill so I've told this a
million but I'm gonna tell it to you
yeah I got real lucky when I started the
people I opened with the first one was
Jim Gaffigan and the other one was Bill
Burr it was before both of them we're
doing like [__] chuckle James gavigan
yeah yeah
James Gaffigan yeah ladies and gentlemen
calm down just go by Jim oh that's a
good idea somebody Sean parkerson lose
the the Facebook you know just Jim
Gaffigan it's clean it's clear it's
clean you got the reference I love it
can you please you got it and you did it
I'm just excited for friendship okay so
I told Jim that I had just been on the
road with Bill Burr headlining yeah and
look it was just it's just an indication
of how far he's come this is 20 years
ago right I go yeah and Bill was the
headliner and Jim went Bill Burr
couldn't believe that bill was like
going out on the road he was just I
don't know what he thought he was just
like a club guy or something yeah now
they're both at the same caliber which
is crazy nobody throws out specials like
it's nothing like Jim like Jim is like I
know 10 specials deep or something and
they're all thorough I know thorough is
the right word yeah they're thorough him
and Jeannie his wife yeah I know I'm
pretty I don't know if he still does it
but what they used to do was they just
take a topic yeah like hotels and
stretch it and just look for any area
and then right and you know what they do
yeah and this is the genius of it they
treat it like a job
they treat it like a writer's room we're
on we're on Keenan because it is right
the episode it is people are paying to
come and see you and yet so many I'm
guilty there are some bits of mine that
would certainly benefit from me and
Jeannie gavigan sitting down and going
let's talk about writing it out but our
ego or whatever or laziness prevent no
one does it but Jim does it Jim will go
what's everything that's funny about
McDonald's yeah and when you see him
working it out yeah 50 60 75 jokes and
20 of them I'd say this if he was right
here he knows 20 of them zero nothing
right just didn't didn't connect but
those thirds 60. that's just yeah that's
30 great ones and then like 10 yeah that
maybe need work yeah if I can figured it
out it's wild that's a lot of fishing he
finished his way Seinfeld's the same way
there are a lot of these guys that are
just like what if you treated it serious
instead of just like cocaine dude I mean
look at Judd yeah judge hyper serious
about it and it's funny the term when I
say nerd I I don't mean that as a
derogatory term I'm just like we nerded
it out I did too you have to broke it
down
even on the black side like look at Dave
you know what I mean like that's what I
think is real thinkers over there for
real yeah and Dave when you see him look
Dave could come in here and Riff on this
room and it would be worthy of a new
special like he's that talented he's
incredible he would get every well he's
just knowledge so he would grab the
reference material right and then go
into the era he'd also understand the
implications of it you know what I mean
like he would he'd understand like the
history of it like that's what I'm
saying so I'm giving him full genius
card yeah and I'm saying every genius
also just sometimes sits down and nerds
out meaning like he sweats and he works
and he listens and he edits he might be
doing a lot of it on the fly but there's
efforting happening yeah to look that
casual like oh you don't care who you
are oh yeah he has a like a room he
likes to work out in in San Francisco
like I was randomly up there shooting a
a bunch of an Old Navy commercial yeah
yeah and I saw like one of his boys
at the hotel like he came up to me in
the elevator and he was like and I saw
the sea on his on his chain and I was
like before I could even say he was like
yeah I'm here with Dave or whatever he's
here too blah blah Mike what
San Francisco like why he was like he's
doing the punchline right I'm like where
never you know what I mean because I'm
not a stand-up I was like where is that
never heard of it
took me a while to find it yeah I know
it's a little it was tucked away yeah
you got to go up and wrap around and
like all this for a minute but I went in
and he went up
I was kicking with him like before or
something and then he went up and he was
just up there like [__] talking for a
couple hours yeah and he was just
working out [__] right or being in the
moment and if something funny pops up
we'll you know put that in the bag kind
of thing right right that was
interesting you know because usually you
see him in his Radio City and it's all
like ready ready right kind of [__] but
even when I saw him at Radio City
hyper writer hyper thinker right you
know that's what I see my example is
always rappers which are the coolest
dudes in the world yeah and I'm like yep
and they're sitting down and going like
what rhymes with skippity Boop you know
what I mean like and that's not what
also means something special to everyone
listening yes you know what I mean I was
thinking about Donald Glover you know
how we all started going yup yeah yup
yeah somebody Workshop that yep I don't
give a [__] I know it looks like Donald
just took his shirt off and got sexy and
went yup maybe but to get to yo we had
yeah like just [__] all of it
yes yes yes yes yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
little John yeah yeah yeah and a lot of
these are taken you know so he'd be like
I like that and they go that's little
John
okay what about yes all of Britain yeah
yeah you can't do it
yes yes yes yes
yeah yeah that you can have that one
good I I mean I even see it
then it bleeds into culture like I take
a Peloton class and they start going
like yeah yeah or like I can't think of
what it is but it's not yet but like
they're so popular you don't realize
that at some point it was some dude
taking a chance oh yeah I was just
hanging out with these uh two young
ladies my friends have a daughter who's
12 and she had a friend who was 12. I
was hanging out with them and you know
that age I remember that age it's hard
oh absolutely what was that seventh
grade 12 is brutal super hard yeah and
everything is what you like and what you
don't like and it's terrifying to take a
chance so I'm there I'm making corny
jokes constantly and they're going like
rolling their eyes and making fun of me
and I wasn't trying to teach them or
anything but I was just like you guys
are riff Killers you know that like
you're and I was like I'm out here
taking a chance
man don't try to take my sales man
that's an idea guy I'm an idea guy it
takes a lot of bad jokes to get to that
good one and then you
when I would make them laugh I'd go we
don't get to that one without those
other ones you made fun of you know
just being rough with them seriously but
yeah I think a good analogy of that is
like the gold rush you hear people are
getting gold over there yeah and you're
gonna go there and just sit there yeah
like dig through and find some [__] for
yourself and don't be embarrassed when
it turns out to be fool's gold or it's
just a hunk of [__] it doesn't matter
that's what I'm trying to say that's
what we're both saying Chappelle it
doesn't matter Kendrick Lamar it doesn't
matter they're all writing dumb [__]
they're all trying dumb [__] Childish
Gambino made some dumb sounds that's
what his job is is to work through the
embarrassment what I mean so take
something like I know people probably
ask you about what's up with that all
the time you could be like that's dumb
you know what I mean that's a risk you
pitch that in the room yeah but but it's
the right kind of silly I it's the silly
eye thriving the sillier the better and
then yeah you hand it over to smart
people to make it smart enough for the
silly to play I guess you know right put
enough nutrition on it so it's not easy
exactly yeah you know grounded in real
you know Lauren hates that [__] where
it's just like unicorns and like
whatever it has to be grounded in
reality in some sort of way right
well you can see unicorns if you do acid
but you have to like put that in there
right right it can't just be like cotton
candy thoughts or whatever but I tend to
wander in the cotton candy world just
happiness
Sugar Factory what makes me tickle you
know what I mean like that kind of stuff
yes and it was a simple idea of having a
talk show not letting people talk that
made me laugh you know what I mean right
then
we massage it on that the same with
Scared Straight I just wanted to like
yell at people basically and they had to
take it right right right right I mean
it's a simple idea but there is
something true look I don't want to ruin
it we can't ruin it
I'm just saying like how much of the
show is about the host you know what I
mean like that isn't that kind of at the
end part of it is like I'm this is my
show in my opinion if you want to do
well at that show it's all about the
host right yes they're weak that's what
I mean and you figure out how to help
them have a good show they're going to
remember you for that that's right
that's right it's not about can I get a
character that the world loves you know
that's what is the obvious eventuality
you know what I mean oh this is
interesting I was saying talk shows are
all about the host you're saying SNL is
all about oh yeah that's what you
thought you were talking about yeah no
no you you went to it for sure yeah and
that to me is kind of the heart of you
yeah that's the Donahue show it's called
Donahue he points at the name anytime
people forget he's in the stage he's
like I'm allowing these people to talk I
may disagree or whatever but I'm
allowing them on my right right and
what's up with that to me is saying like
let's be honest this guy doesn't care oh
he just wants to be silly or absolutely
have fun it's his show it's not about
talking it's not and that's what I mean
like this is what I mean when I say
let's not ruin it by going too deep I'm
just saying I don't think it would be as
funny if we didn't know it's his show
he's asking a question and then he
doesn't listen yes it's it's totally
different though if the guest was like
and stands up and sings where's the
violation right it's not it's not it's
not a joke anymore right the host won't
let the guests yes
you they've been in on the party they
can't be and it has to be his party in
fact you could do the same joke with a
with a party yeah a thousand percent
yeah this is my party and I don't want
anybody to dance it's Kendall dance
Kendall Roy is like I'm going to be
lowered on a crucifix and do a weird rap
at my part it's similar so that's what
I'm saying is these people that don't
know what to do with their power it's
like a parody of power it's a parody of
ego it definitely is yeah it is equal to
like to to wear that outfit or that hair
you know what I mean it's all ego and
she's super into it
and it's wild because it's infectious
and I don't know it's just a a circuit
you know it's a fun Circus For Us yeah
because we don't have to write
you know
Snappy dying kind of stuff you know but
it's it's just the tip of the iceberg
and then we get right back to the party
kind of thing
and we're dying I want you to know we're
dying nothing better than the cutbacks
to like those hoes sitting there like
what you could do it all the best you
could do it and then this is why writing
is important shout out to a strike
that Lindsey Buckingham joke is my
favorite joke of the whole thing yeah
yeah my absolute favorite he doesn't
talk remember when Bill sat there for
years yeah never spoke a word yeah but
still got huge laughs every single time
and it was the button of a sketch I
can't believe set it up hard in the
beginning it never my man is here it
never doesn't work definitely got
something to say we're gonna get to that
for sure yes yes yes okay has any guest
ever done it and you got the strong
sense that they didn't understand what
was happening like I remember when
Morgan Freeman did it and I was watching
and I was like
no disrespect to Morgan Freeman I'm just
like does he get this or is he like what
the [__] was that a little bit of both
kind of I want to say but he's done so
much I think he's just kind of just like
whatever this is no different from
anything like I don't know if he came
there to do that necessarily I think he
was coming there and then they asked him
to do something or maybe they brought
him in for that I don't know I think he
was around New York and then they like
asked the face right or something like
that right because we didn't write oh we
want Morgan Freeman in this you know
right right he's passing that I had to
go explain it to him and yeah he was
definitely dismissive he was like yeah
sure whatever whatever it's like just
sit there and watch it even yeah I'll
sit there and do whatever I have a
choice really you're Morgan Freeman you
don't have a choice okay bye nice
meeting you enjoy the show I remember
but Ernest Borgnine yeah had no idea
what was going on but couldn't have been
happier yeah just sitting there smiling
I remember this loving life and just so
not waiting for someone to tell him
didn't matter he was just loving it yeah
what a sweetheart I think once you get
to that iconic status somebody at SNL
told me the story where John Malkovich
John Malkovich referred to the movie
Being John Malkovich as that weird one
with my name in the title you couldn't
you couldn't remember the word being and
his name you know what I mean like
that's wild meaning like so Morgan
Freeman's is going around being Morgan
Freeman all day exactly and part of it
he was sitting there and you were
dancing I don't think we can even touch
how absurd these people's realities are
yeah that and like there are certain
people that are
kind of distant from you know the
celebration of them you know what I mean
like I want to say like Philip Seymour
or even myself or you know I would it
sounds like John Malkovich is like that
where it's just like off-putting yeah
you know what I mean about him I see so
he wants to be great at his work and
he's protecting himself for that yeah or
it makes it awkward like I don't
necessarily love being
you know the sitcom demon I didn't love
that you know what I mean like they just
grabbed my first name and just made it
all about that like oh it was called
saving Henry at first or some just
normal [__] right and then they were
like no we just want to call it your
name blah blah well I'm not gonna fight
you about it but it's a lot you know I
mean like Keenan hoodies and like all
kind of things you know like it's you
know it's a lot I can't even wear it
well I was just I called my friend maybe
you know Andrew Santino he's a hilarious
comic and we were talking isn't he great
incredible he just had that cheeseburger
special was great I'm so I like I was
just doing the shells this this morning
because I threw a straw out in the trash
show me the show I'm saying it coming
out the door show me the shells as I'm
grabbing my kids to myself I swear to
God
that was two hours ago
no way show me the shells wow wow we
were talking about all those stories
about the devil and you're at a
Crossroads or whatever or he teaches you
to play a fiddle but he wants your soul
and I was like
we have this conversation he and I
probably three times a year it always
comes back to the devil teaching you to
play the fiddle yeah because we see it
people that believe their own hype they
take themselves too seriously you
overload them with money and with money
comes power and then they start and the
other not just that one we all go they
become Gollum uh Lord of the Rings power
corrupts yeah always always and it
doesn't matter so few I'm happy to hear
you say that you have given this some
thought you have a little memory
membrane around you that goes like let's
not start believing that because it's
gonna eat up your life oh yeah but I've
always kind of been like that you know
what I mean I'm definitely
I say I'm Ensemble minded a lot but it's
like little brother syndrome you know
what I mean just like that's necessarily
the leader of the pack but you know
would love to be an MVP like I want to
be a solid player basically but I don't
need the light shine on me like right
not at all Scotty Pippen
sky pipping but he's just he's losing
his mind right now you don't know is he
yeah yeah he's just saying all kind of
wild [__] like oh Jordan was a bad
player in the beginning and all kind of
[__] like really everybody was you know
and then he got really bad but it's hard
for me to believe by the time they met
each other Jordan was a bad player I
don't think so I don't think so either
that that does fill in nicely I always
go to Jordan but it always goes he was
Dorking it out he was bouncing a ball
and shooting a free throw 700 times is
Bill Gates [__] oh yeah that's like
learning to code oh yeah and then we all
make it like he must get so many girls
or whatever and I'm like he [__]
dorked it up yeah who taught you so you
said a little brother syndrome I hear
that did someone kind of model that for
you that like look you'll go nuts if you
believe this or you'll lose your Center
no no one ever like
put it directly necessarily it's just
you know growing up with respect you
know like not super strict parents but
like my parents were strict you know and
growing up at the church and like
kind of being the only one in my entire
family to be semi-famous like my brother
is like doing a lot of work now but we
started out doing a lot of theater
together and then you know he's four
years older so he ended up going to hot
you know high school and college before
he got into like you know
actually booking [__] you know what I
mean and I started booking [__] out of
Atlanta and like 14 15 you know and like
I kind of was just in it young and he
circled back around to it now but for a
long time it was me and like my other
entire side of the family that are in
Virginia just normal people and there's
hundreds of them you know what I mean
right and it's just like who am I
they're like there's hundreds of them
yeah go back to the same basements with
a new attitude you know right I'm I'm
already an established who I am kind of
thing right that's interesting so
there's that Jay-Z quote where he goes
people say you've changed and he goes
hell yeah I've changed you think I did
all that work to stay the same right so
that's the other side of it but I hear
you you've certainly changed and grown
from that kid in the basement yes with
your buddies but you can still maintain
and go back and still yeah I never lost
myself in the in the search for you know
what I mean for the achievement of even
you know like I enjoy being normal and
coming to you know new adventures alone
you know what I mean because I'm a fan
of people and like right I am just you
know an adult that can survive you know
I mean I don't need an Entourage or an
assistant to do everything for me like I
have them but I don't hand over to the
uh publicist couch and then the sleeping
and we got a little dog no that is your
problem this is classic yeah it was a
long night last night a lot of phone
calls yeah a lot of a lot going on I
think that's amazing it's incredible let
me and I'm glad let me ask you Santino
and I I was talking about you this is a
nice thing I was like you're like you
just said you don't want to be other so
I'm not trying to make you uncomfortable
but I think you're like an iconic number
thank you and I think this is even
better than being an icon you say MVP
I'm just like who's funnier like I've
seen you in sketches with one line and
not to put down the sketchment like that
was the best laugh that was his best
laugh but some face or some moment and
you're always staying in touch with the
silliness of it and you talk about
starting in theater with your brother
sort of like School play of it yeah like
you don't have like an SNL
gear that you're getting in and getting
tight you're staying loose and being
silly and having fun yeah trying to stay
in the moment stay in the moment
do that sketch yeah and do that line and
also nobody likes someone who's trying
to get laughs but you're like I know how
to get laughs and I'm gonna go get them
but you're not embarrassed to go get
them that's not that's not bad a lot of
layers to cut yeah yeah no and it takes
it takes time which is kind of unfair
for some people they don't get a chance
to like
get that time to break through that
bubble at whatever you know emergence
point it is season two three four you
know I mean whatever idea that gives
them the confidence to kind of do
whatever some people come in with that
confidence yep you know but a lot of
people
kind of get the job because they're
still on the on the rise of you know
whatever and people are pointing them
out as you know that person has
potential that person has potential
whatever
but you know potential isn't right you
know a good enough Shield sometimes you
know what I mean to like let you just
fly off the handles even if [__] is
going wrong or some [__] like that right
and earning that respect of the audience
earning that respect of the show The
Producers the crew it's a it's a it's a
lot yeah yeah and it you know for me it
took a long time and like that's why I
like being in an ensemble so I can kind
of figure it out from the back as
opposed to like being right up front
let's see and just being judged for
everything so by the time I got up front
I was ready you know what I mean I was
ready for you know whoever's questions
or judgments kind of thing and
I I'm very lucky for that you know what
I mean like I think I'm very lucky that
I was able to perform others ideas until
mine were mature enough to be there what
you're saying I think I sound like an
old person but I'm just like I just feel
like that voice is missing we don't have
enough people saying that like hang back
yeah it's and it's tough because
everything is like
yes
yeah and it's all about me do you
remember in the inside Lou and Davis he
goes you don't release your early [__]
it ruins the Mystique wow do you
remember that no it's crazy they're
finding his old records and he's like
how come I haven't heard this he goes
you don't release here early it's the
same thing I just said yeah but like
people are running to the front and
either you get to the front you don't
know what to do and you explode or
implode but nobody's saying like take
the time and train what's the rush and
also anonymity is is power that's what
Dimitri Martin said to me when I was
starting it was like I know I know you
want to be famous but right now you can
move in any direction and no one's gonna
go what are you doing right you can you
could go up and totally change your
style and no one would mind so you have
the the wisdom to hang back a little bit
and get ready by the way uh Will Ferrell
too he did his career slow I know it
doesn't seem that way yeah but old
school he killed it as a supporting
actor as an Ensign kill it destroyed it
don't just I'm sure yes Will's never
done the show steal it steal it I'm sure
he got offered leading roles in other
movies but it goes back to training and
I remember
being in theater
and us like rehearsing you know just for
the director basically like the first
time him being up in the audience and
seeing the formations or whatever
and I remember him calling out people
that were like in the moment giving to
the scene whether you had lines or not
he would call him out like I see you
working I see you you know what I mean
and it was such a feeling of achievement
to have your name called out
for being noticed for being in the
background for doing you know a
committed you know performance
that was just for the sake of the you
know the piece it wasn't self-seeking
Behavior at all it wasn't like how can I
steal that I think needs to be taught
you know because it is it's satisfying
for the team to win you know it really
is right and
I don't know I'm I'm I'm you know I'm
happy that I'm the kind of person that
allowed myself
I didn't come in not with an ego you
know what I mean I didn't come in not
trying [__] that I thought was funny and
like you know had the train wreck of you
know seeing the fact that it wasn't at
all what was one of those
man I wrote something with like a Pink
Floyd song in it like the money song but
like just trying to sing it but like
it's one of the hardest cadences because
it's in like three three times or
something like it is not an easy thing
yeah it's just a famous song and I
thought yeah everybody you know knows
this song or whatever but try to
recreate it at the table and give parts
to other people and have them with like
two seconds of rehearsal before the
table read man that [__] tanked hard
[Music]
I remember like writing that [__] all
night and being happy about like yeah
this is going to kill right you know
what I mean then we're gonna sing the
song and it's like it's gonna be perfect
not knowing that little things can tank
your sketch you know what I mean right
so well there's a difference and one of
the things I think we all have to figure
out the discernment between your Mania
like you're in a moment yeah sometimes I
look at my sad list and I'm like I can
make anything funny that's a dangerous
place it's much better to go I don't
know if any of this is funny it is and
it's it you know and it makes me happy
that it makes me feel weird when people
say you can make anything fun you can
take any line and make it funny because
like I know that's not true you know
what I mean that's right exactly maybe
it's the only high percentage true yes
the illusion but I can just be like you
know what you're absolutely right let me
just read this emergency exit plan yeah
speaking of
what is it with accents I'm sorry we're
going to take a turn left because
Daniel Radcliffe hosted and you know
he's Captain British but yeah you know
they do the American accent very well
yeah and then he hops back to the
English yeah so I had him like read like
the emergency exit plan just as an
American and he was just like yeah this
then and then he just went back to being
his British stuff I'm like ow which one
of you
are you acting you know what I mean are
you acting the British email yeah you
know when Christian Bale does
prescribing in the accent of the movie
it's crazy I'm like hey just Elba I'm
like what
I have a whole I used to have a bit
about this where I was like actors are
sociopaths of course I'm joking yeah but
I'm like if there's someone in your
office who would cry on command you
found out that wasn't their real voice
everything they ever told you was a lie
you'd be like Kathy's a [__] insane
and we need to [__] tell somebody but
if you film it they're like and the
award goes too and it's like these are
our
tuxedo limousine can I put this to you
too yeah nothing makes me laugh harder
than Brad Pitt pretending to be a
pharmacist and they give him 50 million
and then pharmacists go and watch it and
cry and go that's us I'm like that's why
he's brilliant he stooped to pretend to
be like counting pills with the little
metal things make it real and instead of
them being like this sucks he's doing
he's doing what I do
because
he makes it real he doesn't approach it
as Brad Pitt anymore right he's Jeff he
disappeared Jeff Soderbergh or whatever
one of us yeah that's true so I love
what you said about you can't make
anything funny
it's meant to you have to put your legs
your head between your knees I'm like
who's the real you have to put your head
between your knees you know what I'm
saying
it gives you the chills it's crazy I'm
telling you writing it's insane you're
sitting talking to yourself and then he
walks in yeah and he goes hey Daddio and
which will be perfect because if he says
daddy you don't have to do that because
it's like you're trying to create a
scene that doesn't exist but that's what
I'm saying so you know when someone says
you can make anything funny you're like
dude I'm me all day and I remember the
Pink Floyd Money sketch like you don't
see it yeah and then part of the
illusion like how many times going back
to Jordan did he lay up a brick alone
and was like I'm so glad nobody saw that
or an air ball are you kidding you think
he didn't shoot air balls at his prime
how did that happen that's right here we
go the classic Jordan whoa that is way
off in fact I want a montage of Jordan
Air balls just miss career just bricking
bricking you'd be shocked oh here we go
fade away
[Laughter]
okay that was over the backboard all
right pull it back a little bit got it
you gotta learn
it went into the crowd
okay Jordan I guess that was a little
strong yes
this but this becomes and you know take
your pick De Niro has done movies or
whoever you like
has done movies where he did a take and
it was [__] dumb it was dumb I'm
saying he's one of the greats yeah
that's why he's one of the greats and
this is what I was trying to tell these
two 12 year olds I was like you just see
the finished product you just see Billy
eilish always being cool like what do
you want from me that's that was her and
her brother being like
is that something is that that's
something right and their parents are
just like all right no that is nothing
she's played a track for her manager and
she loved it and it was like but also
people don't even bad they don't even
harp on the fact that people only post
the most perfect thing right you know
what I mean they cut it they edit it
they do this and then the other and they
they throw up you know their best thing
ever yeah they don't they don't throw up
the ramp up nope you know what I mean
the journey is probably even funnier you
know so much like as a comic does not
does it not Elite you when a joke bombs
because it's like well this is exciting
because I was expecting it to go this
way but you're telling me it's gone that
way so what happened that's the attitude
right if you're curious and present yeah
to use your word
and you're just going like
now the joke is right that I thought you
would laugh at that exactly like there's
still a joke happening absolutely like I
did a show where it was just a hell gig
and I just started like kind of turning
on the crowd and and talking about how
much pain I was in and I'm sweating and
I want to die and [__] you and all that
stuff yeah that's the show right
whatever the show is if the show sucks
so much that you're entertained and
delighted yeah then that was the show
yeah that was the move that's been in
the moment that's what that's what it is
instead of pretending like you're
killing I understand like having Your
Arsenal you know what I mean and
throwing it out for the sake of I know
these things go well so if I'm
performing for sure this is the show you
know what I mean but at the same time
it's so exciting to discover that you
know and like it's crazy and it's the
Arsenal that emboldens you to try to
discover yes I remember so going back to
this very well so it states when I think
when I open for Burr I had a set where I
ate [__] yeah absolute [__] yeah and I
you know he wasn't Bill Burr but to me
he was right I was like you're [__]
incredible yeah what do you do you tell
a joke and back then my jokes were so
corny they're all about road signs they
were all about like
things I read on ice packs here's one I
go I was reading on an ice pack that's
the setup it said a bittering agent has
been added to the content to discourage
consumption oh man tell me if I'm not a
Seinfeld fan I got words I know and I go
I love that because apparently pause
before pause the ice packs were too
delicious
now we can appreciate that because
that's just a bad early joke the crap
the crowd gives it zero as they should
which is funny because if I did it now
they would probably laugh just because
I found my fans I found people that like
silly stuff like that yeah but I'm in a
bar yeah in Peoria Illinois it's like a
truck bar yeah it's not gonna work yeah
and I said to Bill I go what do I do and
he goes he goes just be honest be like
well that sucked and I tried it because
I had plenty of shows to bomb in right
next time I do I go the ice packs were
too delicious no one left I go well that
sucked no one even laughs at me calling
it out or maybe they did and then I had
nothing to follow it with right so then
I'm like I read this on some canned corn
I'm just like foreign
like I realized I didn't have the
Arsenal that might be one of my favorite
characters ever the comic that bombs
calls it out and then just moves on
bombs and calls it and he's just still
bombing and calling it out the entire
time this bad joke and well that sucked
that's his tag like hamburger hamburger
and I'm not gonna have it well that
sucks well that oh my God that's
hilarious well that sucked hilarious I
go what kind of an abbreviation for
robot is Robo
you really saving any time dropping that
t
hey robot cop the bad guys over there oh
they got away I spent too long saying
your name and then well that sucks
I saw a road sign on the way here said
caution Falling Rocks like heavy in
literal tears right now oh my god well
that sucked
it was in the back like
he didn't know that once he he and then
he meant so good you know what he meant
be funny yeah don't do comedy be funny
yeah thank you sir just be in the moment
yeah but I wasn't good enough this is
you and your hanging back years you're
cultivating your skill you'd already
done a bunch of stuff but you're
learning
like when I say steal it I don't mean
material I mean like steal some of that
wisdom yeah some of that sure-footedness
that will help you they want you to
steal it because they stole it right
Chappelle got it from somewhere you know
what I mean for sure I'm not saying he
didn't Burr got it from somewhere yeah
and that's okay that's okay that's what
we're doing we're all passing it forward
for sure see what you do with it see
what you do with it for sure
here's what I said to Santino that I
didn't know we were talking about it and
I kind of know your answer already
because your Ensemble minded
and you're grounded and you're centered
and you're grateful and it's incred I'm
so happy I'm so happy to see that you're
this way
but we were like I was talking about how
great you are I won't say everything I
said but just how great you are how
hilarious you are nobody who makes me
laugh harder on that show you're the
king then I go right and I go is he
overrate underrated I go is he
underrated we just had a little chat
yeah and we're like it's the old Chris
Rock thing he goes do you think this is
not my words I love Jay Jay Moore but
Chris Rock said if I was as funny as Jay
Moore would I be on the show it was kind
of one of the meaner things he said for
sure I don't know if you remember that
cuts deep yeah it cuts deep in it and
again JJ love you pal Jay's pretty damn
funny Jay's great that's a little unfair
yeah I agree yeah I agree but he was
sort of I think he was hinting at like
black people don't blow up it wasn't
about Jay yeah it was about race
and that was Santino and I just two
white guys figuring out race relations
but I was like does do you feel
underrated and do you think if like is
that a is there truth to that like why
isn't it cover of Rolling Stone
consistent
keenan-ness would you not care I mean
yeah I've had those thoughts you know
what I mean like
it's definitely been an interesting
position to see people like come rise
and leave you know what I mean come rise
and leave and come rise and leaving like
like when they're Rising it is a
whirlwind of like yeah covers movies you
know this that and the other and then to
be there and like I mean I've had my
versions of that whenever
you know those moments of a you know a
movie I might be starring and pop up you
know what I mean so I never overly
focused on it but
I have had those thoughts where I would
see like the top 100 SNL performer like
book and then whose pictures on the
cover you know what I mean and like what
size they are and then I'm like
interesting and then if I if I make the
cover and it's a small picture I'm like
just like well work harder or you know
be more legendary or whatever like I
kind of try to use it as incentive as
opposed to like you know they're leaving
me out of the conversation and like I
have a chip on my shoulder about that
right
I think once you get chips on your
shoulder that's a dangerous kind of
beginning to a spiral right you know
because you just start being defensive
about everything or you just start being
you know kind of paranoid about [__]
right or overthinking [__] so I'm losing
your footing kind of like it's stressful
enough right and you are doing
incredible
and it's just a very strange fish bowl
to be in oh yeah to have a new fish come
in I'm just saying back to you what you
just said to me and they blow up and
you're like so you were just you just I
feel the same way about stand-up to be
honest like some some people just swing
in to stand up for some reason they
explode explode selling a million
tickets and I'm like
and by the way I'm I'm just joining you
I'm also incredibly grateful you're
incredibly grateful but there are
moments where you're like I don't
understand like I'm taking this real
serious
and dedication matters yeah you know and
it's got to be frustrating especially
the people that kind of but you know our
world is you know it can be shallow you
know what I mean at times sometimes it
just comes down to
you know the Woos and screams you know
what I mean and if you're getting enough
Woos and screams for you know how you
look even or something like that or
right you know the fact that you are a
new fish as opposed to somebody that's
been there and been you know Dependable
or whatever you know how much I resent
losing screams oh my God I will in a
screaming because it it launches people
in a Direction but it doesn't
necessarily allow them to time to
develop so I think Harry Styles was
lucky you know what I mean like he's
lucky that he was dedicated enough in
such a good person enough to actually
pursue his craft
while that rocket ship is happening
that's right you know what I mean and he
kind of surround himself with people
that took it real serious and were you
know talented in there don't leave the
Woos and screams or he didn't let it
stop at woozing screams because he
Coulda well he just didn't let it detach
him from himself you know some people at
those moves and screams just you know
it's like a lazy river just okay take me
into my future you know what I mean tell
me what to do because everything comes
to you all of a sudden right free meals
free flights free women free this free
that free drugs free men if you want you
know whatever yeah you know what I'm
saying and then all of a sudden
you're just out look you're at the end
of the river and now you're out in the
lake by yourself and like everybody's
like well no back there you know
floating down the next one you know okay
so I wanted to say this to you earlier
I'm glad it came back because I think
maybe you've already heard it but they
say if you want to go
fast go alone if you want to go far go
together yep and Santino also and we
were just talking about this it's like
you want to blow up real fast it's
Daniel Day Lewis and There Will Be Blood
it's like you end up in a mansion alone
that wasn't losing screens but it's like
though also those same Woos and screams
they're all gonna get kids yep and wives
and houses or partners and houses and
they're not going to go out and like now
then it becomes like nobody's wooing and
screaming anymore
you didn't establish a relationship of
like craftsmanship or like trust and
then
and this [__] sucks when I see
especially in Hollywood how people like
refuse to get old like they can't
because that's what they are and that is
corrosive and toxic to your soul like
I'm gonna say soul like if you think
your worth is that you can turn around
and people will woo at your ass or like
lift up your shirt and show your abs and
that's your worth what happens Keenan
when it goes away like this is the
oldest story of the book it's the oldest
story in the book and nobody learns the
lesson unless they have people around
them to remind them of the lesson it's
hard for you to be in the middle of it
and just assume one day it's going to
end you know you just think the
trajectory is just going to keep going
because it's going so hard yeah and like
every other day there's an incredible
phone call you know what I mean or
sometimes when you walk outside I'm
literally black churching you right yeah
I'm black church you know this is church
it's why wild and
you know if my heart goes out to them
because a lot of the times they are good
people and then they get put I'm
watching I watch Pete go through and I'm
watching Marcelo you know kind of you
know start it basically yeah and
I think they both will be fine because
they both take comedy seriously like
Pete is a good stand-up you know what I
mean it's incredible and he got thrown
into the biggest version of you know
celebrity there could have ever have
been so he's experienced that right and
he's still standing God bless him
Marcelo is the same kind of way takes
comedy very seriously yep I think it's
you know comedy first and then
everything else is a bonus and it seems
like a really good dude and it seems
like and he's incredibly talented and so
great you know he's trajectory so I
don't I don't think he'll be in the
mindset of you know this will last
forever kind of thing I think he'll
always be mindful of you know his you
know Beginnings you know his family is
this that and the other and that's great
the ones that don't have that it is so
heartbreaking you know what I mean
because it's not like they're bad people
right they might happen to be handsome
beautiful whatever it is and then they
get thrust into the spotlight and then
all of a sudden there's nobody to catch
them on the other side I I would go so
far as to say they're victim like their
symptoms million percent it's like that
South Park episode that [__] was harsh
the Britney Spears like the episode
where they were like sacrificing
celebrities like a community and they
have to harvest like the Privacy
sacrifice they have those myths of you
know their weird internet legends about
how Hollywood they're all drink vampires
yeah and I'm like this is metaphorically
accurate meaning I don't you know think
they're actually going vampire they are
sucking Souls out they are sucking Souls
out and they will use people and that's
why those stories resonate well I mean
those people are using their planes in
hotels as well so that's right that's
right that's right it just needs balance
yeah you know we've all been told life
is about balance so
I don't unapplaud someone who's famous
for the moment you know like I'm not
necessarily A
and you know Taylor Swift is not a great
example because she's not just of the
moment famous but she's hyper famous
right just a hyper famous person
but it seems like she has people around
her hopefully that keep her in a good
place I would agree you know I can't
tell if that's marketing or or just in a
reality place like it's just aware I get
that when I say marketing I just mean I
can't no no one can know but I'm with
you it seems like she's been Billy
eilish too just yeah Kaboom but still
with her brother you know with her
family her this man the other right and
then the ones that are just like out
there floating
you know you worry about you know and
it's it's yeah like they are they're
victims I also did you see Blackberry
it's like how could it be a victim when
they're riding around in a mansion it's
like you know come on first world
problems so probably just right Santino
right we're talking about wealth misery
have you heard the phrase melt wealth
misery no well I just learned it and I'm
gonna use it every day of my life it
makes sense it's a thing like wealthy
people have to deal with like their kids
killing themselves
because the suicide and the homicide
rate yeah if you make over a million a
year crazy
it's because they think they got it they
think they got fulfillment and balance
because culture told them be beautiful
be rich be powerful they did it they get
there they're in the house again it's
why and there will be bloody kills the
guy I mean it's not a spoiler if the
name is
the title is a spoiler but these these
people are victims of a mental reality
of a Mythos just a story that we tell
and when the people find out it doesn't
work
they're literally murderous of
themselves and sometimes of others
because it's not right by the way I just
want to throw my hat in that ring it
might not be a ruler but I can get
confused I can confuse my value with my
brain with my humor that's just as
dangerous nice County that's a good
that's a good dream she's having yeah
buddy she sees it she said go get it
those of you that can't see Scout Had a
Little Dream a Little dreamy that's so
sweet I know I know who's that at the
door
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at p y m choose p-y-m prepare
your mind they are chews that help you
manage feelings of stress anxiety and
overwhelm good news there's something
here to help it's wonderful when you're
feeling worried stressed out or as Val
and I like to say you have a b in your
belly just chew two of these delicious
naturally flavored no sugar added chews
and in minutes for real minutes you
start to feel more centered comp and in
control when I first tried them it
worked so well for both me and for
Valerie that I ordered subscriptions for
both my mom and my brother just so happy
that their anxiety and stress have a
natural non-addictive non-psychoactive
solution I like taking it at the start
of my day when I'm sitting down to
answer emails or something to ease me
into the work that I have to undertake
and I like to take it sometimes at the
end of the day when I want to wind down
and relax away the stress of the day how
does it work Pym shoes are comprised of
proven amino acid complexes and
adaptogens that help support your brain
and your body's ability toward
organically support your ability your
body based ability to manage and
tolerate stress anxiety and overwhelm I
also take their mood magnesium at night
which helps me sleep and unwind includes
three magnesiums with the most evidence
to support their effects on stress and
sleep it's very effective in helping me
fall asleep faster stay asleep longer
and wake up feeling rested the best part
is a percentage of their profits one
percent goes towards mental health
nonprofits including the one bring
change to mind so help your body and
your mind fight off stress and overwhelm
and sleep more deeply with Pym go to P
sorry you can pym.com go to you can
pym.com weird news promo code weird for
15 off that's you can like why are you
c-a-n-p-ym.com weird these promo code
weird for 15 off support your brain
support your mind support your stress
your side of your overwhelm and sleep
better and get 15 off and support the
show this episode is also brought To Us
by our friends at bird dogs the makers
of the best looking best feeling shorts
and swim trunks I have ever owned I've
never been a big short guy although I
love swimming I hate swim trunks but
bird dogs has literally come to change
all of that they're here to rescue our
summer especially now that it's hot I
love liberating my legs and getting in
water as often as I possibly can and now
thanks to my dogs I can do so without
feeling weird I can do it while feeling
comfortable and licking licking licking
really good looking looking really good
bird dogs make you look good bird dogs
also have khaki shorts that are designed
to fit Slimmer through the thigh and leg
giving you a truly sculpted look which I
love and bird dog shorts do the exact
same thing as Lululemon but they fit way
better and they have the added bonus of
not being Lululemon they're not stiff
restricting cotton bird dogs fix that
issue by inventing Cloud knit fabric
that looks just like khaki but stretches
so you get a way Slimmer fit without
having to sacrifice movement and bird
dog uses anti-stink sweat wicking fabric
that keeps you cool and dry all day long
and their swim trunks I love this not
only they look great but they dry really
really fast so go to birddogs.com weird
for a free Yeti style tumbler with your
order that's
birddogs.com weird and you will get a
free Yeti style tumbler with your order
trust me you won't want to take your
bird dogs off we promise you alright
back to Keenan
anyway I'm just saying
I don't want to say like oh I'm just
looking at the the beautiful people that
shoot up fast I also my wife does this
my daughter does this I'm going to tell
you this I wanna I wanna see what it
makes you think of I said to my wife in
a moment of vulnerability
when the baby when Leela was young
and I just go what if when she's like 16
I'm not doing anything
I'm embarrassed that's the funny
episodes was a real question it's a real
question because I want her to think
Dad's cool yeah and dad is admirable
really more than cool admirable like
look dad goes for it I look up to my dad
yeah and Val said it changed my life she
goes you'll be her dad
you right
is that a tear jerker she goes she don't
she's not gonna care what movie you're
in or what that's awesome you'll be her
dad you'll you'll have hung the moon so
that vow not a show sometimes it takes
someone to tell you that though yeah I
mean it's hard to just have that
perspective that's it you're like that's
a light bulb moment you know I love a
light bulb moment it's like oh wow like
I would never was thinking about it that
way right but what did I learn two days
ago oh that the Venetian I was just in
Vegas the Venetian is because it's
Venice themed I thought it was just like
overall Italian and it was like they
wanted to call it the Venetian and then
I thought about it and I was like gone
unless I've been on there for years I've
lived in Vegas before
and just never put the two into it I was
like oh it's black vintage but I thought
it was like a lot of different Italy
yeah like no it's Venice themed and
Venus people are called venetians
there's another the the wheelchair I'm
45 years old I love it we're the same
I'm 44 but we're the same The Wiltern
isn't it the will turn theater it's
Wilshire and Western
come on we'll turn theater okay thank
you for letting me know I've been there
a million times
wait did you say you lived in Vegas I
lived in Vegas I lived out here I lived
out here for like eight years back right
after high school but when I got the job
I was living here but I didn't want to
pay New York and California tax at the
same time because
it's such an unpredictable thing so like
every year I didn't you know I was West
Coast putting like my agents to manage
lawyers everybody was out here
so I was just like not sure you know
what I mean so I still had like one foot
West basically so I moved to Vegas
so I could come in and out and like work
the biz or take meetings or auditions or
whatever in my Hiatus weeks because I
just didn't know how New York worked I
thought it was like Hollywood and TV and
film in LA and then like the music
business in New York or whatever right
not much like film [__] right and I
wasn't wrong it wasn't you know a whole
lot of just like TV shows and movies
there was certain things that you know
came from La basically so I was just
like let me just stay close to LA or
whatever and then you know after like
four years I was like man probably just
do the New York thing for a while it
feels like did you like it in Vegas
I loved it because I lived like away
from the strip I was just that's what
everybody out in the day everybody
pictures you living yeah in the pyramid
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah just writing
the Luxor just [__] doing shows and
buffets like
no I lived way out uh in Lake Las Vegas
it was just like 10 minutes from the
Hoover Dam it's like kind of middle of
nowhere you know planned Community thing
and I would drive into the strip to like
go to dinner and [__] or sure Penn
Gillette he's out there or Brian Regan
no I was I just was to myself basically
yeah
but you have a family you you I do now
no this is before yeah before this
before yeah yeah okay okay uh all right
where were we oh not overrated with the
thing the jealousy yeah you're I mean
what did you be her dad's like what were
you yeah what if you know like at 16 it
reminded me of how I was feeling about
the strike it was like what if the
strike goes on to where I would have to
get a job I've never had a job you know
what I mean like I used to cut grass
it's not a job I would get 20 bucks per
loan or whatever but that's not a job
you know you're a kid you know can I
please thank you just I mean so many of
us out here are having the same thing
it's almost like what would I do it's a
post-apocalyptic situation yeah and
we're all going around realizing just
how worthless we are not we're not
really but not that helpful I'm not like
every day I can't cut your hair nope I
can't cook your food I'm sorry what do
we do
and then start learning some [__]
Santino and I were also laughing about
how
when we look I'm all for the strike
obviously and I stand with it with both
strikes I'm I'm about it I support it I
also just think it's funny that like
it's such a detached industry from what
everyone else so I was just in Missouri
we were just visiting some friends by a
lake being a family yeah it was awesome
and when I heard people talking about
the strike you I mean we like to be like
Union strong like we stand with every
Union and I'm like there are people in
coveralls that do not understand what
we're talking about at all and you know
like I'm not a big fan of striking like
I really wish you know there was another
route because this isn't the 80s like
yes it's the biggest track since the 80s
but this is not the 80s anymore right
like this is going to be a global
problem if this goes on for like a long
period of time like every movie I've
watched lately like the credits are just
very long especially anything with CGI
internet or whatever thousands of jobs
and people like you and me totally
different I think about my friend Kat my
friend Kat is coming she cuts my hair
she's my dear friend been working
working together and friends for over a
decade yeah I'm like that's what she
does she does hair on show like so
whenever I'm like oh man I I hope this
wraps up I'm like there are people that
their attitude is not oh boy I hope this
wraps up soon and it that that's who I
really feel for yeah man I mean it is
it's wildly detached from
you know a lot of people like a lot of
people don't even realize we're striking
you know I mean they're just like every
day it's like so what are you up to
right now I'm like nothing we're
striking what do you mean it's like I
mean striking yeah yeah is that what
you're talking about just getting rid of
some Lumber I could use some Lumber like
when is it like for sale you're going
way too far with what's not happening
sir none of that is happening
oh yeah and yeah to have to like explain
it like huh
They Don't Really sympathize immediately
they're just like yeah interesting no
back to you know well my life is you
know whatever whatever whatever so you
should be fine regardless but it's not
necessarily like that for everybody
going back to like wealth misery you
would never think
you know a billionaire would have issues
type thing or their kids might have
issues right they do you know it's just
Dynamics uh my friend Rob Bell he's a
brilliant writer we were saying now when
a billionaire has kids when we were kids
we were like imagine if my parents were
billionaires like Richie Rich yeah it'd
be the best and now when a billionaire
has kids you you feel bad for the kids
yeah you're like how could you even
remotely you know what it is you need
that perspective yeah I keep saying that
word but it is
and very very important because you know
what to appreciate you know you need
rain so you can appreciate the sunny day
right right you know what I mean that
it's pretty much that simple I was just
thinking about that on the drive down I
was thinking about what I would tell my
daughter is I'm like everything you want
is on the other side of something you
don't want and that's just how it is
that's just how crazy you give me the
courage after you do the thing that
scares your [__] man that's right it's a
law of the universe you starting out 14
did Scary [__] [__] that would have been
easier to not do much much much much do
you remember tell me about those early
shows because don't let me go on and on
I just remember being sick that I had a
show like oh yeah just nervous the
Nickelodeon years weren't this is all
that bad all that was not that bad
because there were seven of us like King
was different King kill was like me and
him and then we come out in front of
that curtain and it's like screams and
like I introduce myself it's a scream
maybe and then care would introduce
himself and they would go crazy
just like yep that there it is then you
guys screaming for it so we got a sure
do and like more work to do and just
like
a lot going on especially for a young
person to like you know process and not
you know derail with like what's wrong
with me why don't they screaming with me
like man make it competitive yeah I mean
like I was just you know I was proud
that they were screaming for him but I
did have those thoughts like you know
should I work out more to get more
screens we just had Josh Peck on the
show you know Josh yeah that was the
same issue I forget who his partner was
but everyone would Night and Day Josh
yeah I mean yeah he he went Drake oh
yeah he went hard at it yeah but that
comes and he would say that came from a
pressure and inadequacy like a strange
feeling yeah those thoughts can creep up
but
I don't know I never let it overtake you
know or just hyper bread which I
probably should have said you know Josh
looks great you know what I mean yeah
but you look but at the same time I feel
great you know yeah and that's I think
what matters people are different you
don't need me to tell you people are
different but like you know what I mean
we can't all we can't all
I don't want to cut I don't you got to
work and sacrifice too much for me to
have that well it's funny when I was
thinking about telling my daughter that
I was like
the good feeling of exercise comes after
something you really don't want it's
very painful it's very painful yeah it
just and you know what I'd like someone
to say and I'll say it to my daughter it
just sucks it sucks yeah I wish it was
so life stinks so just a brilliant title
like life stinks well it's that it's the
fire in the house that dude doesn't want
to go in his house his house is on his
house is on fire he's got buckets it
would be easier because you gotta do it
that's not a hose you know how many back
and forth exactly but there's nobody to
help him he's got to do it he's got to
do it and it sucks but the feeling of
having his house and the fire being out
yep will be worth it but it's on the
other side we're talking about Keenan's
tattoo if you're just listening to the
audio it's on the other side of a lot of
[__] buckets yeah there's a story I
was thinking about it earlier I won't
tell the whole story
but talking about losing your innocence
often in myths your innocence is is a
ball like a a ball of Light which makes
sense because a pregnant lady's belly
looks like a ball of light like it's the
most innocent State we're always trying
most precious beings when they're
pregnant yeah exactly and you were
precious you were one with your mother
no I'm concerned one with God like you
were just like completely you just you
didn't even know you were and yet you
were yeah that's that's a good
definition of pure light yeah and we
lose it and we want to get it back and
that's what so much of our Endeavor
endeavoring is is to get it back so
anyway there's this story and he has to
there's a uh I don't want to tell the
whole story but there's a guy like an
Obi-Wan kind of figure but he's at the
bottom of a lake and he's in the woods
and everybody that goes in the woods
dies they drown in the lake so a guy a
brave knight you know the hero of the
story goes in to retrieve this kind of
sacred holy man that could that could
retrieve this goal this ball of light
from him but he's a scary hairy man
it goes in the woods and instead of
going in the water which is what
everybody did and that's why they drown
he just buckets it out one bucket at a
time and that's what they say couldn't
you cry it's just it gave me the chills
just remembering it's like nobody just
wants to go bucket bucket bucket he
emptied the lake instead of going in the
lake and drowning this is what you were
saying earlier this is what we're saying
about this social media [__] Lord like
you know people running to the front you
know people just Dive Right In and these
myths are thousands of years old some of
them they're [__] old stories
Parables which means they're they're
you're supposed to learn and it means
even back then yeah Jesus Christ was
like these two sir yeah running right to
the front yeah yeah take it there was a
slow
they're gonna kill you anyway so just
right why rush to the guillotine that's
right yeah interesting that's right
where did you learn this be present in
us where did you learn this
this when I say smallness I mean good
small
um I don't know if there was a specific
moment I've always really just been a
fan you know what I mean I've been a fan
of everything like yeah you know
anything that was making me laugh making
my friends laugh yeah good music food
you know like you're in a free shows
yeah I think so you know so
I've kind of always just had that like I
enjoy like a a flower that's blooming as
much as you know
ginormous boobs or weed or whatever it
is you know what I'm saying I think
you're gonna say like a Beyonce concert
yeah yeah but what is it what what is
the thing in common between appreciating
a flower and appreciating a Beyonce
concert is being there it's dropping
anchor and just just like a post I was
looking at on Instagram and it was about
like
you know people being in the moment or
whatever so it was like
the guy that just joined the team that's
from Buenos Aires or whatever the soccer
player's name
what's his name like the guy that just
moved to Miami messy yes thank you
Messi's doing something in a game and
everybody's got their phones out
watching and David Beckham is on the
sideline without a phone just like
watching yeah and then next page was
LeBron breaking the scoring record and
everybody's got their phones and cameras
out and there's like one rich dude you
know just watching you know and you
there's validity to both because yeah
it's nice to watch things back or record
things or whatever but balance man you
know
when are you going to watch that video
and what will the state of mind what
will your state of mind be when you're
watching the video are you going to film
your reaction or your friend's reaction
chasing the Dragon's Tail man never ends
it never ends talk about old stories I
think it's it's not Madame Bovary [__]
it doesn't matter
there's a there's a very very very old
story about a young lady who was cursed
to look at reality through a mirror so
she's walking around and she can only
look in the mirror
and and my professor at the time Dr
Stein he goes if you saw it doesn't
matter Janet Jackson but it was in a
mirror would you did you really see her
you know what I mean it's like it's kind
of what's Happening yeah I see all these
things I saw a dude on an obstacle
course like a rock wall swinging he
looked like like a Silverback Gorilla
like the strongest primate I've ever
seen yeah swinging flipping on the bars
he had a whole routine and I watched it
did I really see it I just saw it in a
mirror I just saw and I went on and the
next thing was just like someone's
omelette did you really experience it I
didn't no and you
would get more out of just a flower
perceived presently than a Beyonce
concert or whatever spectacle the Super
Bowl I've been to the Super Bowl I was
too busy thinking in my mind I wasn't
there drop in and be there I didn't
learn how to do that until later yeah
drop in and be there it's important
because
I think those things
fan the flame of your your fanaticisms
you know what I mean and you get it
tells you who you really are and what
you really like yes you know what I mean
it's like because when you're president
you don't like something it's obvious
you know it yeah you know it you know
what I mean and when you're present in
something's awesome it's insane yeah
like the first time I saw Travis Scott
was at a [__] Festival in New Orleans
the voodoo Fest and you know outdoor
Fest I don't do them much because it's a
lot of people yeah and this was a lot of
people and it was supposed to be Donald
Glover but his father had just passed
away that weekend so Travis had stepped
in and I wasn't too aware of Travis I
got to heard a couple things but I never
seen him live and I didn't really know a
lot of his music
and we're waiting all this Sunday you
know it was a weekend Festival so like
they've been partying the whole time
like my wife and her friends you know
and
I stayed back Friday and Saturday you
know just to relax because I can't do
fast it was three days in a row I just
was like I'll go the last thing for the
headliner you know what I mean and
that'll be my thing a couple hours I'm
out of there
and I'm like yeah oh I was Travis Scott
I don't know much Travis Scott Travis
Scott what's this going to be like we're
waiting we're waiting we're waiting you
know the headline has to go on when it's
dark finally or whatever that's how you
know it's like you know exciting time so
it was very still
you know in between the last acting when
Travis was going on for like 30 minutes
you know what I mean and then like
all of a sudden he stepped on stage and
within two seconds everybody around me
was twerking and then there was a
hundred thousand people jumping up and
down at the same pace and it was just
like Jesus this is a whole lot of energy
all going in One Direction you know what
I mean like that's amazing yeah it's an
amazing thing to witness right instead
of going he's playing my favorite song
yeah no that's what he opened with yeah
he just saw
did the same is true of traffic one time
I walked in my garage and I was very
present and I I looked I have two cards
our family has two cars
I just looked at two cars yeah I saw
them yeah I know this sounds I have two
of these I go what the [__] the [__]
these huge they're metal Engineers yeah
engineered there's two of rubber Fabrics
seat belts yeah but you know people do
stuff and I was like I could go far I
felt eight years old and I was like my
parent I used to have a line on
soundstage ago my parents have no idea
where I am right now yeah and I felt
that freedom again I was like I could
get in one of these cars it's one of my
favorite Brewer jokes Eddie what's up
it's like when you're single you're just
like let's go across the world tonight
we'll get on a train we'll be gone for
three weeks I think when you have like
responsibility you can't do that [__]
but when you're single it's like the
world is your oyster yeah yeah what's
great about me is I never wanted people
like Jim that would be like let's go on
a road trip I I crave the excuse of
children could you just send me a
postcard yeah
I'm going to the deli that's what they I
went to school on the East Coast they'd
be like we're driving to the LL
door
because it was the only thing that was
open 24 hours or whatever and I was like
nah I'm good but I had to come up with
an excuse yeah well uh tomorrow morning
yeah yeah yeah when you have kids you
just go I can't leave yeah even when you
get a good excuse I was like yeah the
dog greatest excuse to not come and also
leave early
kids I mean look
don't anyone go and have kids just for
this but do it 30 for that
absolutely that's valid that's valid
there's some Worth to doing it earlier
yeah tell me a story about
a host or somebody on SNL or maybe
anywhere that that impressed you with
their humility and and with their
presence Chadwick was a big one I mean I
mean Tom was like one of the ultimates
like when I first met Tom Hanks and he
called me by my name
before I was able to introduce my voice
is so classic yeah hey Kanan I was like
yeah exactly hey Keenan I couldn't
handle it because at the time it was you
know the biggest movie star probably
ever you know what I'm saying like
nobody's done the back to back
exactly Mano Street one million percent
and could not be nicer so like that was
crazy and like it said like between him
and Spielberg like it's like yo who do
you think you are that you're not gonna
be nice to people right like these guys
have achieved so much yes you know and
they're still very present look you in
your eyes they know they know who you
are you know what I mean kind of thing
if you're on the radar or whatever this
is what you're really
see this is a gift you're giving me and
hopefully the listeners is like fandom
is precious yes and Tom Hanks does not
need to know who you are no and no
nobody does I've heard Eddie Murphy by
the way apparently Neil Brennan told me
he knows everybody because he watches
everything yeah he's a fan so I'm like
you think Eddie Murphy watched my
special he's like definitely he just
that's crazy that's what I'm saying yes
and I'm like but why
when you get big and powerful and you
don't have to care because what is
caring caring can be used as a social
contract I care about you Keenan I need
help I need food I need shelter I need
money I need medical whatever so that's
like a manipulation that as you know
animals we sometimes do that like it can
be a little fake so they don't need to
do that right they have all their needs
met and yet Tom Hanks took the time Tom
Cruise I've heard is the same way
hyper the same way really like I'm such
a fan of Tom Cruise it's crazy like
he's so dedicated and I think the whole
Scientology of it is a reflection of his
dedication more so than how weird that
religion is I see you know that she got
in like he likes it he got in but you
know he's also in pursuant of something
and they were fulfilling a big part of
it when he was pursuing I'm with you say
I know there are bad things to say he
found an energy like you at the crowd
with the jumping out and he found a
group that was like we are literally
militaristic about self-improvement they
never was in the military loves to
salute he loves to play those roles
where he gives respect to those ones
because he was never one of those but he
would have been if he wasn't an actor
kind of thing is his mentality or
whatever right right but also he wants
to be a high-powered individual and he
found people to help him get through
that trajectory you know what I mean
like all they do is give him toys and
let him go play in the desert you know
what I mean and he shows up here and
there to allow them to recruit for this
thing but he's not that connected don't
think to the indoctrination of all these
people in my mind I think he's just
being Tom Cruise you know it sharpens
him yeah he gives him a yeah
I can't be completely naive which is
burdening because
in his pursuant he's you know gotten
mixed in with you know
a situation where he can't just
peace denounce you know what I mean or
whatever and peace out and just be like
I'm just Tom Cruise now I don't
associate with those people anymore kind
of thing right and I think you see him
wearing that but on the other side of it
he is hyper humble and aware you know
what I mean and like he does his
research but isn't I think this is a
clue and this is the gift that I'm
saying you're giving is like
[__] needing to be a fan yeah out of
some social manipulation or wanting to
belong wanting to be taken care of these
people are teaching us that past well
past the point of needing it yes the
point of life is to surrender to it and
to appreciate it like Tom Cruise and Tom
Hanks were both vulnerable enough to let
your work into them and isn't that the
definition literally you could trace it
back to the way our brains work the
remaining whatever neuroplasticity is
like the remaining porous yeah they're
becoming a fan of something new like you
watching Travis I'm going to become the
fan of something new what is Bam from
that moment on and what is the opposite
of that rigid like these are rivers
stiff yeah and dead unappreciated dead
no one likes you right you know that's
us that's a salty in existence not to
take anything away from Saltines
Saltines are great when you're sick you
know Saltines in a Coca-Cola that'll do
it every time that'll get you back so
that means something that matters but
going back to Chadwick
Chadwick was another hyper humble
individual that I was surprised by
because he was having the biggest week
ever like the biggest week I've ever
seen in the black cultures like guys
basically like
yeah Denzel does a training day here
whenever we're used to that from Denzel
you know we're used to him being like a
leading man in a movie yeah this was the
first black superhero moment in Marvel
when Marvel couldn't have been bigger
yeah you know what I mean and
everybody's excited about this movie
Black director yep hyper black culture
moment that week and he could have been
walking around in a dashiki and you know
right you know and really been on one
but he was Beyond humble and focused and
just on his toes like you could there
was no way you could tell that he was
suffering you know what I mean and
knowing that and watching him for six
days
it was really really
impressive like staying porous you know
what I mean vulnerable it's like the
opposite of this rigid yeah nothing gets
to me yeah no you can't you have to
surrender in a way especially like
the story of that week for me as far as
like stress is concerned was we did the
Black Jeopardy and black Jeopardy had
been going so well Tom Hanks was the one
that did it last right before that and
it was like
I think it was like a Maga hat kind of
character or whatever yeah that was like
the biggest you know kind of like
societal conversation good comedy piece
to get the dinner table combo starting
kind of thing
you know there's another one yeah easy
easy
can you believe there was a time that
sketch was like shaving in ice water
with a very
even me watching it I would say
something mundane and everything
explodes yes it's like nuclear Holocaust
I was nervous for you I was like don't
know
perfect so
big moment for you know a Zeitgeist you
know cultury thing for a sketch that's a
big thing for a sketch I remember so
when Chadwick came it was like we should
do a black Jeopardy because you know
more than likely you know at the
beginning at the base of it he's black
you know what I'm saying so why not do
another Black Jeopardy but topping Tom
Hanks was like all right well we need to
make this definitely do that because
Chadwick deserves it he's having the you
know the biggest moment or whatever yeah
but we didn't quite have it down pack
until
I think damn near dress rehearsal we
were still tweaking and then afterward
he was still finding it you know what I
mean he was like questioning should he
be you know like an African or should he
be actually t'challa you know what I
mean or whatever
and um
he never he never buckled to the point
where he you know just checked out of it
or you know tanked it to cut it not to
do it or like voted against it or if
people do that to get to cut it oh yeah
oh yeah yeah oh wow because they don't
get it or don't want to do it or
whatever kind of thing yeah it's like
whatever
and whether they know it or not you know
what I'm saying like you know they they
end up taking it wow and that is it's
harsh man because it's like I wonder if
this would have been good if that thing
didn't happen yeah whatever right Bill
Lawrence just did it and he talked about
table reading yeah with actors that
would tank the whole episode was that
bill I think that was actually somebody
else somebody told me about a pilot and
the actor hated the material so much
they tanked it on purpose the show
didn't get picked up obviously I'm like
terrible what are you doing what are you
doing killing everything deserves a
chance yeah absolutely please put your
back behind it a little bit which is why
I try not to laugh during sketches
because it's like you want to service
the material as written to see you know
what I mean or whatever sometimes [__]
is funny right you know what I mean I
can't help it right to us I don't need
to try to hold it I don't think of you
as a it's weird how we've sort of
culturally changed on that yeah yeah
yeah it used to be like everyone was
like don't do that then it became like
we love that more than anything now
we're in a nice Gray
not too much yeah but yeah Chadwick
finally found it and the live you know
show was the best it had gone you know I
mean which is such a blessing well so
Chadwick passed which is a huge tragedy
but it's doing my heart well to know see
this is my point one day lived in the
style that you're describing that this
man was doing yeah is better than 90 100
years
where you're not where you're looking at
your life through a mirror yeah where
you're never there you're just you know
a crotchety person across the street
you've never been anywhere yeah it's
like sometimes I talk to people like
that a lot of yeah I won't say but you
know people I know
and you you'd be like I remember we were
talking about like Italy or something
and they were like I've never been to
Italy I'm like you've never been here
like you think you're gonna go to Italy
and suddenly become that's my favorite
sketch of all time maybe is Sandler
Sandler was great it was brilliant it
filled a blank in I I referenced that
sketch constantly for those that don't
know because you're in Italy if you're
sad in New Jersey yeah you didn't change
from 250 pounds to 120. that's right
you're still 250. and you're yeah and
you're if you're not a blindfold in
Strawberry
yeah and they have diagrams to be like I
can't stress this enough if you're
depressed here and you come to Italy
you'll be the president yes and if
you're not a blindfolded strawberry
person at home hilarious you're not
gonna be a blindfolded strawberry person
in Italy and it's like oh my God yes
it's it's recognizing that everywhere is
Italy
traffic is Italy this moment is Italy
yeah we're waiting for something to
basically scream and woo us we want it
to like just give it to us but this is
kind of like saying everything we want
is on the other some other side of
something we don't want what we don't
want to do is be vulnerable enough to be
present
Yeah because sometimes the presence
present the present sucks sometimes you
know what I mean like it's a long flight
to Italy and if you're flying coaches
even longer you know what I mean it's a
long process that's right on the other
side of that process is Italy right you
know what I mean right and I've had
moments on flights I can't always do it
I mean I'm watching movies I've seen
moments on flights are you kidding yeah
like I remember
I have the awesome opportunity to like
go to can for like a technology
convention like it wasn't even a film
test it was like something like techcon
or something that they were having
there's a free trip great took me you
know my
oldest daughter was like one years old
at the time
and
or maybe like
10 11 months still like still in the
stroller a very big stroller basically
so she was that age
and
we were flying from Tampa because we
were living there and
you know we connected through Atlanta
and then in like Paris and then to like
nice or whatever to get to can blah blah
so everybody was like it was smooth you
know like
leaving out of Tampa is like the easier
TSA thing you know what I mean so we're
already through looking at the bright
connecting in Atlanta it's fine it was
like we had to run for the plane it was
like last minute kind of like whatever
was a delay it only gave us like 40
minutes or whatever but we weren't
concerned we made the flight great
fly all night
just when I was getting my daughter down
like I made a little bed for her on the
ground or whatever kind of thing like
because we were we were flying first
class I'm not gonna lie it was nice so
there was area it was a free trip in
their life yeah it's not like I was
throwing her under the seat it was like
there was an area so I made like a nice
little blanket area and put her down and
it was like everybody was it was dark
and it was perfect
she was about to doze off
the guy in front of me turned his
[__] light on
and he's like I lost my phone in my
chair
looking for the phone for 20 she wakes
up
and is up the rest of the flight and I'm
like
[__]
nine hours or eight hours or whatever it
is she's up and I'm like walking around
the plane with her feeding her bananas
letting her just put bananas all over
this just playing we get to Paris
this is a nightmare trip talk about
being in the president sometime the
president can suck yeah get to Paris
it's like five in the morning we got a
connection flight but only like an hour
to grab it or whatever everything's
going fine until we get to like a
security checkpoint and they ask us
where's the ticket for the baby
and like in America or on Delta they
just put it on your ticket yeah they
don't give you a separate ticket yeah so
they're like no the chicken that she has
to have a separate ticket in Europe or
whatever and we're like [__] what are we
supposed to do like go back to the
airline counter or whatever
and the Paris airport is not easy with a
stroller there's like in levels that you
know a person with steps can do you know
what I mean because it's all like Modern
Glass like go up steps and then go over
here and then go downstairs and it's
that area right so we had to take slow
ass elevators to do everything clocks
ticking
get to the airline counter it's six in
the morning so of course that diapers
fall now so my wife's over there
changing diapers while I'm arguing with
these people that they didn't give us a
ticket they're trying to make us prove
that it's our child all this extra [__]
and I'm like finally give us the ticket
looks like they just never gave us a
ticket in Tampa you know what I mean
like we just checked yeah normal blah
blah blah yeah we wanted to Casual yeah
Americans
two more elevators you know what I mean
blah blah blah running for the flight go
through security like luggage x-raying
and just like praying that they don't
pull anything aside to give the double
check is this Cheerios or not like
please let us get there get there last
people on the plane whole plane looking
at us it's like all right cool we get
there fine right fly Denise get to niece
no luggage
I can't the thing I had to go there for
the holy the the meeting I had the only
meeting I had to go there that gave us
the free trip was that morning
and I have banana shoulders all across
my black t-shirt or whatever
I was like all right I'll go shopping
but it's can and every shop is like
Europe Couture and soccer jersey [__] I
was like I'm [__] this is like trying
to get a bathing suit at a like a
five-star hotel you're like this is
gonna be 300. 8 30 a.m at this point you
know what I mean it was the longest
night ever and I just went with a dirty
shirt it made for great conversation
because everybody could sympathize like
yes I had a long flight with my daughter
and they lost their luggage and here I
am in front of you but let's talk about
a virtual yeah whatever the [__]
incredible but
after that it was like an eight day
European Vacation kind of thing yeah you
know what I mean like right it's on the
other side 30 minute thing that morning
and the rest of the day was free and you
don't really remember it yeah and you do
but it also this is another thing Rob
Bell says all I remember is the nice
things that's right the worst things
that happened become the good stories
and then you got all these other nice
things yep we were just flying with my
daughter
yesterday Jesus we just got home crazy
and I was holding her because she was
crying and she needed to go to sleep and
I held her this is another this is kind
of like a contrast to your story
and I was like she fell asleep but we
were Landing and I was like please don't
make me like I got this baby I'm her
seatbelt right and they didn't it was it
was a nice little they let you just keep
it the other way
they look the other way God bless him
God I mean because if you're crashing
everybody's gone anyway it doesn't
matter right
I but that's such a blessing when it's
like just yeah I know the rules and I
know the concert but just let this I got
it it's the sort of and we don't have as
much of it I feel like we had more of
that I know there was more recklessness
as well yeah but in my childhood in the
80s 90s I remember there being more
whatever that is
more is this the time yep I just had it
this morning dropped my daughter off at
a new camp she's she's nervous she
warmed right up you know what I do I beg
you're this way too I start a little
party I get in the mix yeah flipping
kids around it's so fun like show her
that they're not dangerous much you show
how to do it yeah what's your name the
kid doesn't say anything to me I'm like
all right talk later cool just keep
moving it it's fine it's all right kid
had sunscreen all over her face I go you
wearing any sunscreen I'm doing bits
yeah having a great time nobody got that
one but there was a rock wall not a
maybe a foot and a half off the ground
and then the playground and my daughter
just as anyone would God climbed over
the Little Rock Wall
when I say this wasn't dangerous you
would laugh in my face if we were
watching this and I go that wasn't
dangerous you'd just be like why did you
even bring me to urbanize that yeah
and this one of the teachers goes we go
around I'm like oh
that that's making me buckle up my
sleeping baby like don't just let it go
yeah yeah know that there will be a time
later when my daughter isn't scared
right but there's a certain look the
other wayness yeah that was good in the
80s and 90s you know I blame yeah
Corporate America tell me Insurance yeah
money you know yeah if that kid falls if
your kid falls whether she can handle it
or not yeah there are bad people in the
world that have yep ripped people off
rip people off right you know the apples
just spoiled certain things yeah
we have the capability to fight back
that's right well my wife and I were
just laughing about this we go parents
that go life isn't fair
and I'm like we don't we don't say that
life isn't fair [__] you you're in the
way right make it fair now yeah give me
two cookies do something to balance that
fare you know you're the Arbiter Affair
In This Moment moment well life isn't
fair well what are you trying to prepare
me for right like there'll be plenty of
free range examples of me getting
customers do we have to do this now
right can I have a fig newton between us
right now life's pretty good right you
know what I mean in this in this house
in the room right I feel like there's so
much
to burn down our house in the world and
look but I don't know I don't know how
to talk about this but I'm like people
seem to believe that worrying is helping
yeah
and it's not be informed but getting
obsessed and getting Moment by moment
speculation from newscasters on these
situations I want a super cut of Jordan
missing yeah and I want to Supercut of
people on the news saying [__] that
never even came close to happening and
turns out just like what you and I do it
was just some writer going say uh maybe
if uh if the plane hits the nuclear
power plant uh the Eastern Seaboard will
be uh everyone will die that's why the
weather people aren't my favorite
they're like we think that's right okay
stop yelling at us because we weren't
totally accurate but they're the only
ones we do yell out
yeah they never that no nobody goes back
because it's a drug you want to panic
and then I resent that people say to me
like you're not informed enough or I'm
worried that they would say that I'm not
informed enough I'm like know enough to
know how to vote and where to donate at
the end of that you're just getting off
why is your television watching somehow
ivy league right it's not it's not you
watch television you watch TV yeah and
then you Rose don't because there's so
much to read and know about just in
books that's right they don't have time
for TV
Eternal truths but you know who supers
in like that um
and we call them oh we well Tracy calls
them Obi Lauren Kenobi yeah yeah he's
like we go on 11 30 now because we're
ready you know what I mean it's because
it's 11 30. that's right and he's like
he approaches it
a lot of different things that way is he
like a I'm only asking because so many
like a father figure to you did he
become like that for sure I mean he's
like the fourth one you know what I mean
like I've been very lucky to be
surrounded by like good you know Mentor
kind of people or whatever but he
definitely is like Father Figure to you
know a lot of us you know what I mean
but it's like a it's like Neil Brennan
syndrome he's the youngest of 10. you
know I mean like I feel like I keep a
distance with Lauren because like
he always just wanted to be like hey
come with me and go over here but like I
just have this fascination with what he
represents yeah that I'm like a little
distant like you know who am I to like
text Lauren and like call him but some
people do you know what I mean but like
I'm just I play it the same way I'm a
little bit of a barrier of like man that
dude is on a whole nother level and like
you don't just
tuck up under ginormous dragons like
that and then it might accidentally step
on you you know what I mean or scratch
you or in some sort of you know what I
mean that was my she gets painful I did
Fallon back when Fallon was the old
Falon yeah when people were like I
wonder if Helen's gonna make it
and I did stand up on that and then I
walked in the it's a 30 Rock and I
walked in the hall and Lauren walked by
me and he didn't say anything I'm 44 now
Keenan of course he didn't say anything
of course he didn't probably didn't see
it yeah what do I think he's up in his
office watching the feed but I did when
I was 20 whatever or 30 whatever I was
like even speak interesting and I called
Melania Melanie was like
he he did me a real favor he's like you
know Pete when you do a show and you
murder and you're like just super in
yourself and feeling great you're a
dragon you're briefly a dragon and you
walk out and there's an open Miker there
and you don't look at him and go
you're the next great one right that's
what happened yeah it's not about you
he's killing his own thing and he walked
by yeah but that's the dragon thing I
let him squash me because just for a
moment I was like
is this when you tell me I'll be honest
with him is it yeah it's like yo no a
little bit of distance yeah but protect
yourself yeah he drops dimes like that
and yeah his you know approach to it
he's very like straight face like
whatever happens you know what I mean
like yeah you gotta be don't let it make
or break you how did he well there's
people that have gone there and left
early or left quickly and it has broken
them you know what I mean when there's
people that have gone and left early
that it hasn't there's people that have
thrived because they just got a splash
of what that show can do for you as far
as like getting your name out there and
then they took their talents and
continued to thrive you know what I mean
right which is
where you want to aim for in my opinion
yeah like you don't want to like put
your hopes and dreams all on one
specific thing because if it doesn't
work out it wrecks the other 50 40 Years
of your life that's that's crazy right
right
we can edit this out because it's not
that kind of show but was he Zen when
Chappelle did the monologue that no one
was ready for yeah he wasn't I can't
picture him being like what is happening
right because he knew that they had had
the conversation like I think even in
like hallway joking it's like you know
it's going to be a completely different
monologue oh yeah and I was like yeah of
course I would expect nothing less kind
of thing right right and it's not like
because it's Lauren's burden to care
those aren't his words he's like yeah
but you gave a platform like that's not
how it works right you know what I mean
and like also Dave's not a hyper like
malicious individual either you know I
mean it's just a processor of his
personal thoughts and aren't we
supposedly allowed those things I guess
right in in you know away where I guess
it doesn't overly harm individuals
necessarily and we've gotten very
sensitive these days so it's hard on
stand-ups I would I would have to assume
well first of all I'm not that way like
meaning Dave has that he's a little
rascal yeah I mean that as a compliment
he's out there he really wants to push
it yeah and find it yes I'm kind of do
an ice pack 2.0
do you ever look at the back of an ice
pack look that I'm actually selling
myself short I think you are you realize
well that's kind I wasn't fishing but if
you really look at what I'm saying I I
just did this new hour I was like like
70 of my new special like I'm like it's
about death I'm talking about death like
I I'm joking about this but it's like
underneath that there's this like what
the [__] we die the whole time so I'm
doing my own version but Chappelle is
doing doing something completely
different from all of us different from
all yeah I mean he's just a different
special guy but yeah that's his talent
you know what I mean and a lot of people
have theirs and if you focus on it and
and stay true to it and take it very
seriously yeah it will
I think pay off because like
the legends of those those that seem
like
they make it look easy if you will yes
like the legend of John Legend
is the fact that he was in the piano
room like notoriously in college like he
spent yeah eight hours a day right in
the booth and people could hear him
right and they have those memories of
hearing him before he became that's it
because he just that's what he works
yeah he worked at it yeah that that's
exactly I know we've been making that
point a lot but I don't think we can say
it too much to me
yeah the world is there's toxic
individuals that don't give a [__] that
are just constantly trying to chip away
at you or whatever and they're vampires
that'll stop you and squash you thank
God
okay so the war of art Stephen
pressfield just did the show and he was
talking about he was like be a
don't look to people look to places so
he's like when Arnold Schwarzenegger is
having a rough day he'd go to the gym he
didn't look to people to tell him he was
great he just went and worked at it yeah
and all of these we've been talking
about rappers and Jordan and all they
all did the same thing they were
locational yeah Jordan went to the gym
John Legend went to the piano room it's
like Kobe never went to the club he went
to the gym right exactly and I've told
the story a million times but Gary
Larson the guy who The Far Side remember
the cartoon he sent out 15 submission
packets to every newspaper in town he
didn't hear from anything yeah anybody
and not a single one got back to him he
decided to get in his car and drive to I
think it was Chicago he drives to
Chicago goes into whatever the Sun Times
walks in Waits For A Meeting shows him
his stuff they're like this is
incredible and they gave him a gig he
drives home what's in the mailbox 15
rejection letters and if he had waited
and gotten those rejection letters he's
like I wouldn't have had the car urge to
drive to Chicago so go to the gym go to
the piano room go to Chicago go to
Chicago yeah be locational don't wait
for letters in the mail to tell you that
you're worth it that's definitely
something I try to I just told this guy
in Vegas yesterday he was a security
guard like bouncer in the club and he
was telling me that he he's an actor you
know he was like do you have any like
you know words of encouragement like it
wasn't advice like what do I do blah
blah blah and I was like yeah stay
focused but you need to get to a
platform like Las Vegas is not an
actor's platform there's not a lot of
theater there right you got to put
yourself in position to have opportunity
yeah so I was like you got to get to LA
or New York however you do it even if
you do it from Vegas you know what I
mean like I get to go out there for a
day or two of the weekend or whatever or
get a gig that'll give you an apartment
you know what I mean something like that
right but you gotta get to where that
stream is Flowing right if you want to
catch those particular fish I was gonna
say you want to get struck by lightning
try putting on a tinfoil hadn't walking
in a field you know what I'm saying yeah
you got to put yourself in in a position
to succeed you can't just have dreams
and then and then sit there guy also
might just have too many people in his
life
that aren't encouraging him and we need
to stop looking to those people yeah I
mean either that or
societal pressures maybe whether they
are you know bills or right of course
you know you you know your parents
telling you need a regular jobs you can
you know have a you know sustainable
future you know what I mean the actor's
life is not you know predictable like
right and it doesn't make a lot of sense
for a lot of old-minded kind of people
right
right don't be naive necessarily like if
you move to L.A and you just get
rejected eight million times maybe dude
pivot when I was shooting crashing in
New York every once in a while some this
happened more than once that comic would
come up to me and be like I saw your
show and I moved to New York and that's
what I'm doing I'm like sleeping on the
subway and I'd be like
don't do that yeah
don't be delusional that's a show yeah
we exaggerated how rough it was you
should be a waiter yeah
what you're doing is
paying you in a way that that's how
you're living is like maybe make a
different decision I completely agree
follow the dream that's following you
that's what I always say so like that's
why I love cliches that's it you know
what I mean they mean they mean things
it took me 20 years to get to that
between that and like motivational
quotes or whatever like neon little
little things here or you know words
written on the wall that'll just like
matter whatever the [__] that's right
follow your bliss that's another one
what's the other side of that coin you
know what I'm saying right you you don't
motivate yourself you know you don't
Inspire yourself with little things like
what life is that we're talking about
embarrassment it's like cliches are
embarrassing or a little or being again
vulnerable enough to need advice I bet
if you give Tom Cruise or Tom Hanks the
examples we had earlier advice yeah I
bet they would be like thrilled you know
if it was something if it was good
before if it was good they would
be over the moon that's what I'm saying
to discover something absolutely not to
put myself in that company but
Santino Birbiglia when we learn
something we share it with each other
and there's no like
you think I need that right I swear to
god dude that my whole life I would give
my dad a gift and hit go ah just exactly
what I wanted like like [__] with us
yeah because I swear and I love my Dad
I'm just saying like no one taught him
how to receive a gift and he thinks I I
can't confirm this
I swear he thinks that if you give him
something he takes it as like an affront
like you think I need this and I
couldn't buy it so
myself but that attitude can be rough
yeah you need to be vulnerable enough
it's like both the Paradox of
vulnerability and Company it also gave
you the awareness that people are
different that's right you know what I
mean like not everybody sees the world
the exact same way you know and people
behave differently it doesn't make them
bad necessarily
their perspective or their sense of
humor like it might not he might have
been before his time that's that's true
my dad also says it doesn't make me a
bad person but he said that's his other
little catchphrase yeah no no he's he's
taught me a lot I'm not just saying that
um we usually talk about the meaning of
life you talked a little bit about
church growing up
just so we don't go forever not too long
and take too much of your time where
where are you at now do you have any
thought system spirituality yeah I mean
I'm very open to you know anybody's
opinions on a lot of things basically
like I dismissed the you know toxicity
or
negative or evil or anything like that
anybody that's on the light side and the
love side of things yeah I want to hear
I'm in highly intrigued you know what I
mean I'm like intrigued just by even the
origin of language like I just it's hard
for me to process like
these different cultures and societies
speaking in a way that they completely
understand each other you know what I
mean and I have no idea what they're
saying that's right at all and it's just
mind-boggling I took a class in college
that was about that and I just met one
of those 12 year old girls that I told
you about one of them spoke German yeah
and I was like English came from German
photo indo-germanic if you listen to it
it's like broken English right exactly
and I was like I say that as if I
understand it I don't it's [__] crazy
it's like a living
bacteria spreading across the planet
that mutates and changes and even the
concept of time in one lifetime when
you're reading about these things is
hard to gauge totally how much time that
had to take that's right you need to be
floating Society yeah watch it visually
you know what I mean so like
just that awareness of how big the world
is and like what a tiny aspect in
comparison to the universe is concerned
is kind of like that you are where I'm
at you know what I mean and I'm happy
with you know my mentality that I do
like nice things I like to hustle and
work for the things that I have and [__]
like that or whatever
but at the same time my heart goes out
to The Struggle and like those are
struggling and I'm never detached enough
to know that
you know even though like my life might
be straight or whatever
it's not necessarily like that for
everybody I'm just not just up in the
club that's the Gratitude too yeah so
you're having some zoom out meaning like
even language is a miracle so that's
wonderful yeah not that you need me to
tell you that I'm just saying I think
it's wonderful and also some gratitude
and some humility it's funny Richard
Rohr this Franciscan that I love he goes
all you need to know God is patience and
humility and I'm seeing both of those
things I think it's beautiful it's
beautiful man and life can be beautiful
I know life can be [__] I know life can
be
violent or traumatic or whatever but
there are things that make it worth
living or make it worth trying to fight
for to get to those places where you
know the traumatics moments are you know
diminished and you know the better
moments are you know heightened or
whatever that's right and yeah that's
what we strive for especially fighting
for you know your kids sake type thing
yeah like I get worried when it's too
hot you know what I'm saying I'm like
are we destroying our planet way too
fast like we definitely are but I'm like
this is starting to feel like this [__]
might be over in a couple years right
right can we do something about that
kind of [__] right so like a symptom
yeah let's not
like don't panic but also you are
coughing up blood yeah maybe go to the
doctor yeah
I please I look at the planet like a
body all the time and our attitude I
think a lot of it is
just existential dread we're like we die
so what's the point that's one of the
easiest ways to get into that's the
sound of depression well it's not going
to happen in my lifetime right yeah and
then you're like well the planet's gonna
die but so am I right so what's the
difference so let's chop down the rain
forest and you know have a little bit
more beef yeah or whatever you know what
I mean and I'm like we need to learn to
love ourselves yes and each other it
goes like this yourself each other then
the planet you know what I mean like but
to love anything you sort of have to
love everything and we're not really
being taught how to love and it's almost
can seem vain or something yeah because
you know
societal pressures or whatever is just
very competitive and once you add the
competitive aspect to it as opposed to
the communal aspect that's right that's
when things start to go awry but you
know it's so embedded in the culture
with you know
sports or who's going to get the girl at
the dance or whatever the sports I'm not
interested to like yes be the one that
loves everything you know what I mean or
whatever we've been talking about this a
lot but even in the action movie I love
Top Gun and the message of Top Gun is go
It Alone yeah except at the very last
minute when you need a little bit of
help yeah and go to and I love I I'm
using these examples because you and I
both love T Cruz love him Mission
Impossible is the same Ethan Hunt is
gonna go alone until the very last
minute when someone's about to kill him
and someone else is going to shoot him
some version of that but that is also
what we're doing it's like you can see
it in climate change denial is like
it'll be fine at the last second
someone's gonna shoot the bad guy for us
and it's like I don't know if it's gonna
work like that I don't think it is but
it's they didn't make it up that's what
I'm saying and I'm not going to go so
far as say we're all victims but there
is there's a story being told that you
didn't make up so when you meet somebody
that's like no chop it down kill the a
billion pigs a minute uh so I can have
the McRib whatever yeah pick your issue
or oil or I'm gonna fly private planes
or whatever it is
it isn't coming from nowhere it's not
coming from a heart of Blackness it's
actually being informed by our culture
and our stories yeah we we live in a
country that's constantly starting Wars
and and constantly fighting and
murdering it's like bad parents that
tell us not to murder each other yeah
and then we're going off and you don't
even call that murder you know what I'm
saying I'm just I'm not trying to give
anybody a pass I'm just saying we are
swimming in a certain type of water and
it changes and informs everything every
lens we look through is that water so
I'm trying to say nobody's evil just
certain people are you could say
mentally ill or being deluded by
American corporations American violence
American war yeah I mean it's hard to
imagine being born with hatred you know
what I mean like there are some [__]
kids yes but you know most
you want to assume that a baby is
innocent you know what I mean because
it's it is I would go so far I I won't
use an example but like you take a a
troubled person a bad person who keeps
stealing just to keep it nice and simple
if you took that person and resourced
them
it might be medication it might be
therapy it might be embodiment we might
be talking about a weighted blanket we
might talk about exercise we might talk
about a diet change we might talk about
massage uh whatever and really resource
them and get them down slow them down
calm them down at their base level they
are in you and I've said this before no
one at their base level is Mega Death
but we think they are we think those are
the bad guys take the Mega Death person
the person who's so tense they're
shaking they're gonna they're dangerous
yeah bring them all the way down
everyone at their core is the same one
thousand percent you know brings me to
one of your favorite jokes of mine
I'm not afraid of anybody because
everybody sleeps oh you said my favorite
jokes of yours I was like you mean I
don't have a joke of yours yes
everybody sleeps and who are you when
you're asleep you're just pure awareness
just cuddled up and trying to imagine
the biggest bully yes under the covers
oh I'm touched that you even know this
just dusting his feet off before he gets
in the cover turning the pillow over
because it's cooler on the other side
little baby brilliant little baby man
yeah that's the kind of thinking that I
think you know an audience you know
should be grateful for when they see a
comic like that because you're shining a
light on you know the things that is
easy to not think about that's because
we're stuck going to work or we're in
traffic or right we want to hear our
favorite song on the radio or you're
just distracted by life kind of thing I
appreciate it and when you can slow it
all down and be like hey
do you ever think about this right right
and not only here's a technique that'll
make you a little less afraid yeah you
know what I mean yeah it's like
everybody's hungry or everybody gets
scared everybody gets like Hey we're all
hungry I just discovered oysters so if
you want to eat these things we'll
survive but
you gotta gotta do it everything you
want is on the other side of something
you don't you know
and in this case it's these oysters yes
sorry the first guy to like convince
people of that right is a g absolutely
and then was like this could have been
fine yeah this is fine dining yeah one
you wait just wait this will be fine
dining it was a lot of um Lobster too
was a I don't know if you can call it a
peasant food but it was like food yeah
like a pork belly of course all these
things that are now uh just Cuisine the
creme de La Creme yeah I want to say
pate if you will I'm sure
duck liver you're gonna make it you're
gonna overfeed a goose until it explodes
you're telling me that I was going to
the rich guys the Rockefellers didn't
know that that was the help it was
literally it's like the funniest visual
to try to get something what what are
you doing
funny and it's terrible yeah uh I'm only
worried if I'm allowed to say the help
yeah it's a good movie yeah it was a
good movie
um will you in closing tell oh God I
could talk to you forever I'm so tired
I'm I'm really this is part one this is
part one we'll do it again
um
one I just want to compliment
uh let me see it again
can we I mean we don't even have to talk
about it it just made me happy to tell
you my Val and I go do it to me again
it's you it's him and Maya Rudolph doing
this very you and Maya are similar
people thank you and that's silly the
greatest she is the greatest she is the
greatest she's
one of the most highly peoples I've ever
seen but also just a beautiful soul I I
completely agree just a beautiful and
loves to laugh that's I think the
Infectious part about it like that the
whole pocket of sisters I have when I
first came in yeah they love to laugh
yeah like love it yeah and they can tell
they're trying to find it yes we're back
to what dude this this conversation is
what I needed yeah like don't forget
the fandom the finding what you like
it's very Rick Rubin it's like your
taste get in touch with it find what you
actually like you know instead of what
you think you're supposed to like or
what might make money or this or that no
dude it's okay to like what you like
yeah it's totally fine in fact you're
doing a service to society and to
Culture by getting in touch with what
you honestly like like Tim Burton I was
I was just watching something about
Batman and how Batman Returns was kind
of a flop that's because they gave him
more control yeah sure but he did it and
he has an aesthetic that like if the
Pictionary or or the Draw Something clue
was Tim Burton I could get you to guess
it into to like three sketches for sure
that's a special thing yeah that's a
very special thing they think Batman
like with Christopher walking was the
Flop and Michelle yeah really because
the first one was huge and then the
second one was very dark remember the
penguin bites a guy's nose yeah Michelle
Pfeiffer gets pushed out a window but it
is a classic I mean you and I know but
tell that to McDonald's that sponsored
it God put out Happy Meals and then
parents were like [__] you this is a
dark movie got it yeah that's wild
people are pissed and that's why you
didn't didn't direct the third one right
and then the third one was Clooney I
think yes it was and they dropped Tim
Burton and that's why it was horrible
awful horrible it is crazy and then the
next one was Batman and Robin which made
us all forget Batman Forever right and
Batman Forever was terrible but it gets
a pass because Batman and Robin was so
much worse
[Laughter]
so good
it is so good I should just kept
spiraling until Christopher Nolan I know
shout out to NOLA shout out to Tim
Burton too man and shout out to Michael
Keaton and shout out to why we're
striking which is what artists for
artists is about my production company
yeah and you know it's about artists
having you know a piece of an IP as for
the duration of Abby that's only fair oh
I didn't like it's not fair that Michael
Keaton doesn't profit in any sort of way
from Beetlejuice because there would be
no Beetlejuice if it wasn't for Michael
Keaton you know what Tim Burton told him
character description wise what he was
like this character is based on the
charcoal man in like Brazilian culture
there's a guy called the charcoal man
that can go in and out of dimensions
that's all he gave him and Michael
Keaton created Beetlejuice thank you and
what do you mean he doesn't make any
money he doesn't get residuals yeah I
mean he got maybe I mean but it was yeah
40 years ago but it wasn't like merch he
doesn't get like anything from the
Broadway show or the cartoon I mean from
the Broadway show like they're kidding
me yeah the cereal someone is going on
stage and doing an impression of Michael
Keaton and Michael Keaton just cut to
him in the crowd being like yeah not
getting a piece of none of that it's
crazy you know we're all in the
mortality but I can't say happy birthday
but yeah you know without paying it dude
exactly that's it's wild so yeah we're
fighting that good fight but more people
can have the mentality to help that
fight as well not just you know striking
like you can have a company yeah a24
yeah 824 said yes to all the demands
demands you know what I mean all the
desires I don't know what to say
whatever it is pro strike you know what
I mean so
um it's it's an interesting existence
but I didn't know to be lived what is
your production company again artist for
artists yeah is that a number four or is
it F4
it is for because I'm going to be
emailing AFA Keenan at artists for
artists.com and just see if it works you
know something like that'll work I think
try a few different variations
dude there's a lot of those
somebody told me about emailing
Spielberg they just guessed Spielberg's
yeah I don't think he replies I mean but
I'm sure he he saw a few of them
probably he got a few you got a few he
can't open that script though everyone
needs to know no one can read or even
hear your people inappropriate I don't
think people know what it's it's not
also not legal it's not legal that's
what I mean
like I got a great sketch idea and I'm
like you great but I can't read it
unfortunately you even emailing me I've
had people accuse people of stealing it
and the person didn't even open it but
because they sent it because I can prove
that I sent it to you yeah and it's like
this don't so don't do it I just had
some very don't do it and like weirdly
like SNL like I don't know if it was
last year or the year before but there
was like a few
like sketches that were just identical
and I think one of them might have been
a rip or something like that but there
was a couple that were similar very much
to something else somewhere else like on
YouTube or something or whatever oh yeah
and you know I know that you know it
happens like great minds or whatever
kind of thing but like one of them was
like suspicious but it was just weird
that it like it happened a couple of
times you know yeah yeah yeah which is
like maybe we're all kind of sourcing
from the same material and nobody's
being individualistic enough or whatever
right but
you know it's weird when that stuff
happens and you want to hold that you
know it's not just from you know an
actual full rip-off this is like the
insurance thing people ruined it some
people did do that right and now I it
depends on who the person is and and you
know the reputation and the work
but like if you were accused yeah like
they stole it would have to be like well
look look at all the other stuff he's
never done it right you do kind of need
that precedent you do because it's like
stealing people steals things it's just
like no everybody's just similar minded
like I'm Super Mario Brothers movie came
out so we're all doing sketches on it
basically you know what I mean that kind
of I think there was an SNL sketch that
was similar to one of the Batman
sketches we did and at no point did I go
I just stole that they stole that yeah
you know why yeah
you know what it is a lot of it is just
first to Market like I feel so grateful
that we made the Batman's kisses because
we did one the first one we did was you
know every time they turned their back
Batman runs away I'm like what if you
catch him right and there are other
videos I've seen them because YouTube
suggests them to me yeah and I watch
them and it's someone doing the same gag
and at no point do I go they stole that
I'm like
you know that's the 100 Comedians and go
yeah find the joke exactly all 100 would
say what if they turned in something
right I was just the first I don't even
know if I was the first I'm assuming I
was one of the first right that was like
What if they caught him yeah comedy has
a certain it just that's boy the
bullseye is yeah that's right and that's
where the bullseye is and if two people
hit the bullseye you're gonna hit the
same Bullseye right and then sometimes
people are thieves I mean it's both
it's crazy yeah yeah but
balance yeah that's that's the whole
thing nobody wants to steal
no nobody wants to steal and get called
out on it that's right you know what I
mean like Carlos Mencia is where didn't
want it I don't think so I think he
wanted
to do well right
it's also look who cares
he did a bit that was a Cosby bit and
the story I heard was people told him
and he was like it's different and I'm
like that actually and I don't know
Carlos I'm not trying to start some [__]
I'm just saying
the issue is almost always ego it's like
you just who's doing it it's the biggest
the biggest people the most powerful
people if you have hundreds of thousands
of people cheering and screaming and
loving everything you say yeah that's
the space and it's not a safe space or a
natural space it's the ring of power but
it's a protected space yeah and you can
be up in that little you know
command console a little area that's
protected it'll be in that bubble that's
right you know what I mean Until you
realize the rest of the spaceship has
you know evaporated that's right and
it's just that little bubble and it's
dangerous people are intended to have
that amount of influence and power and
money and all that stuff but if you
remove the ego you can easily give
credit to and be like well my thought on
this was this and right continue the
thought process of that same joke but
the part of me that empathizes with that
is I'm like we don't know people do dumb
bad things they make bad decisions yeah
when someone's handing you your favorite
drink at your favorite temperature and
they won't look you in the eye as per
your orders or whatever it is not saying
it did that just saying it's power
corrupts
and you know it's not a passion I
empathize it's
a good kind of existence when those
things are happening for you it's nice
to have a butler you know what I mean
but you don't have to treat the butler
like [__] and it doesn't mean you get to
steal people's jokes but I get why if
all you have are framed paintings of you
and you're drinking a drink you'd be
like I did The Cosby bit a little bit
different you know what I mean it's
different that's where mistakes like
that get made yep you gotta watch the
movie Blackberry I really liked it it a
lot of what did you watch it it's it's
what we're talking about yeah you get to
a point where you're that successful and
that powerful it always eats itself and
it's really interesting that Blackberry
Blockbuster all those things that's it
you know what I mean all the BL and nope
that's it just BL just BL
even the BLT has seen better days in the
in the 80s and 90s people love it there
was something special about the
separation to keep it fresh and cold it
didn't work because it's still in the
same container so that [__] got just as
steamy yeah but the attempt is yeah
absolutely here's the last question can
you tell me a time in your life we're
talking about laughing and Maya laughing
am I talking about the mcdeal team I
think I'm talking about the mcdot that's
what I'm talking about I knew what you
meant yeah
I think we all knew you meant the big
deal
[Music]
um
can you tell me the time in your life
that you laughed harder than you've ever
laughed in your life or barring that a
time when you laughed tears down your
face and you hurt you're laughing so
hard
sitting on this couches like anytime
there's something new and exciting like
the tears start flowing and that's when
I'm like really enjoying it yeah like
it's like oh my God that was so funny in
Vegas we just pulled off without my
buddy being in the back seat if I could
have sworn he was I could have sworn he
was there he's [__] calling my phone
I'm holding my phone like showing him
like yo you're pocket dialing me or
whatever he was not he was not back
there and I look I'm like oh [__] he's
not there answer the phone yo you guys
left me [__] hilarious you were so
sure he was there because it was like
the third time getting in the car for
that day or something so everybody just
gets their seat and we're all in there
you know we're adults yeah you know
we're leaving so everybody gets in the
car
unreal it's really a compliment you're
saying to him you know how to get in the
car of course like you know how to put
your seatbelt on big big guy champ come
on champ
but it happens you know often and I
really appreciate it when it does like I
love a good solid laugh but growing up
it was always a lot of fun to catch you
know the giggles in church or where it's
not supposed to be happening you know I
mean it was just so good and then I
remember
I'm I think I might have gotten the sun
poison or something because
me and my buddy were like we perform
this planes like Seville Spain in the
summertime and it was like Outdoors or
whatever and we were out there for like
some hours and then when we got back on
the bus me and my one we weren't even
all that close but all of a sudden we
just connected on this one thing and
just had this laughing fit that was so
intense he was laughing so hard I was
like laughing at the fact that he was
laughing so hard and it just kept going
back and forth like that and it was
insane because like
he had other friends in the in the play
group yeah I had like maybe one thing or
something but all of a sudden we were
just like connected in this moment and
we just thought maybe we got you know
sun toxified or something because
hilarious I don't even remember we were
laughing at but it wasn't that funny
that just happened to me with see I love
I love going to kids birthday parties I
never got to now I have a kid now I go
to kids birthday parties they're so fun
yeah all these little kids and they're
so present and so open there's this
little kid
three little kids but one of them in
particular I was just doing bits for him
and before I knew it silly stuff yeah me
and this kid just started a little kid
just started laughing that we were
laughing right it was Heaven on Earth I
saw him this morning when I dropped Lee
at Camp I was like hey remember when we
laughed and he was like do I ever do I
ever it was joy and afterwards this is
self-serving but the parents were like
you're so nice to play with them I'm
like I just did
yeah I was oh so good so just be open
folks be open folks yeah that's my
Chappelle all right all right be open
man
he doesn't talk like that anymore he
used to that was easier that was very
this is the [__] way of this is very
groveling it is
this is the [__] way for eight
minutes
yeah
there's a problem yeah there's a problem
in the world when you think these
[__] are doing this and they're
not that at all
we're getting Grizzly Chappelle these
days we are yeah it's my favorite my
favorite special of his is I love it so
much because this [__] will sell
out Radio City Music Hall
tell four minutes of jokes and then
preach for two hours yep yep and like
I'm like that is a man or that is a
prophet right that's right we're
listening it's somebody that gets it
because you're on stage everyone's
listening what are you gonna say and
he's the he's literally the only one
that's like I'm just gonna I'm gonna try
to change society every night basically
right right yeah crazy ew
um that's it would you say keep it
crispy it's just how we end the guest
says the catchphrase how did I not
notice keep it crispy over my shoulder
this whole time oh it's in your shot too
well
keep it crispy folks this has been part
one
part two we only talk about Fat Albert
a
oh that thank you man
[Music]
oh yeah